Hey Freak bitches.
We're back.
Dadda Dadda Dadda Dadda Dadda Dadda
Dadda Dadda.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience
podcast is brought to you by stamps.com
if you run a small business out of your
house,
the last thing you want to do is fucking
measure shit and weigh it at the post
office.
Good googly Mowgli,
Joey Diaz,
good googly Mowgli.
You don't want to be in that fucking
line talking to some person that doesn't
want to talk to you waiting and waiting
while some asshole in front of you is
trying to buy stamps.
Tourist me do this shit on your own
computer.
It's way easier.
You do it all printed out.
You measure it yourself.
They give you a scale.
It's US sweet deal.
If you click on the old school,
you look in microphone in the upper
right hand corner and he used the code
word j.
R.
E.
Get this special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer
including a digital scale and up to $55
of free postage.
It's an excellent service.
One that Brian Red Band himself uses
when he sends out those kitty cat tee
shirts and makes it so a person can
actually run a business from your house
with no bullshit.
So go to stamps.com use the code word j
Ari and get your super sweet offer you
sexy bitches,
which includes a digital scale and up to
$55 free postage that stamps.com and the
code word is jre.
We're also brought to you by audible.com
the best resource on the Internet.
If you're looking for audio
entertainment,
whether it's books or radio shows like
the opiate Anthony show,
I believe they have some podcasts on
there as well that we thought they had
Dan Carlin's podcasts,
but we were mistaken.
I want to talk to Dan about it.
He was like,
no,
you're just making that shit up.
I love that guy.
What a great guy,
and he's a great guy.
If you listened to his podcast,
you'll like him even more.
Once you listen to the podcast,
then you really liked the guy because
you're like,
ah,
this is fucking,
this guy's like,
he's making a masterpiece.
You know,
what we're doing is just sitting around
talking shit.
And uh,
I appreciate that you guys enjoy it.
But the amount of effort that goes into
doing one of these,
it's,
you know,
it's so tiny compared to what he's
doing.
He's essentially doing a real audio book
every time he released as a podcast.
So it takes a few weeks to put each one
out,
but they're masterpieces and the,
he's so dramatic.
Like it makes,
uh,
it makes listening to history exciting.
Um,
but there's a lot of fucking cool books
that they have on audible.com.
There's a plethora over 100,000
different titles.
They even have standup comedy.
Uh,
I know they have some of my shit up
there.
Uh,
it's a a sweet,
what does that Ender's game?
Who's a,
what book is that?
What does that,
I've heard of this before.
It's a,
it's a,
it's the war with like in a hundred
years into the future.
It's really good.
It's a 20 it's 20 years old is really,
Huh?
20 years ago was not that long ago.
How weird is that?
I see coming out about it.
I just think 20 years ago it was like,
God,
it was so long ago.
And when you were a kid,
it's like God,
20 years ago it was the 19th sixties
what the fuck?
You know,
how ridiculous is that?
And then you realize,
oh,
that shit happens rather quick.
Yeah.
Which is really weird when you wrap your
head around it and you think from 1950
to 2013 how different shit is,
but it's something,
you know,
63 years,
August is on my sleeve over.
It doesn't seem like it was just August
two times.
Fine.
So what does this Ender's game?
This is there.
They're making it into a book.
This is an audible book off,
but they're also making it interesting
to me and making it into a movie.
Well,
the beautiful thing about all ball is
for fucking traffic.
And if you're on a plane or something
like that,
if you don't want to listen to a
podcast,
if you don't want to listen to us,
this is a great way to go and over a
hundred thousand different titles.
And if you go to audible.com um,
you can't,
why is the fucking,
hold on.
Sorry.
I think there's like a new thing we have
to say with audible.
No,
which one is no at Squarespace.
Squarespace is a confusing one because
they want the number afterwards.
Went Joe Eight to track the month,
I think audible.com you just go to
audible.com forward slash show you get,
yeah,
that's all it is.
And you get one free audio book and 30
free days of service.
It's a sweet deal.
And uh,
as far as like a resource of information
of a,
of cool audio books,
nothing can fuck with audible.
It's an amazing site.
They also support standup comedy.
They even had a live thing where they
were doing every week.
People would do like a new five minutes
and shit didn't really work out because
that's a lot of fucking time to come up
with in five weeks.
People don't like to think that,
but to have like a rock solid five new
minutes every week that you're really
proud of that you'd want to put online.
That's hard.
Yeah.
So Steve Marmel was doing that.
He was doing that every week.
I remember the uh,
they had a contract with him and a
couple other dudes.
You know,
Marmel is real topical,
so he was like trying to like just
constantly right topical jokes about
Funny Shit that's happening in the news
or what have you.
But it was a,
it's fucking burn it off.
That's a lot.
That's a lot of time.
That's too hard to do.
You mean you could do it,
but man,
you gotta be on the ball every day if
you want it to really truly represent
you.
So I think they stopped doing that.
But they have earth by a John Stewart
does.
John Stewart read it.
He's got to read it.
You can't have somebody else read it.
Scroll back up.
Not that one.
Is that,
uh,
God know Penn Jillette's does he read
his own?
Ah,
that's it.
Of course he did.
Yeah,
of course.
Why didn't even ask Sarah Silverman
fucking destroyed on the roast.
Jeez.
She's hilarious.
And she reads her own shit too.
She's a very funny person.
She's in my opinion as far as like a
chick standups and I hate to break them
up into checks,
but I'm going to do it anyway.
You know,
she's like top two,
three all time.
You know,
women have been like,
I mean,
and I know a lot of people say,
what about Lucille Ball?
She's more of a comedic actress,
you know?
And as far as Standups,
I think Joan Rivers is the queen,
I think.
I don't think you fuck with Joan Rivers.
She's been funny for like 80 years and
you can't fuck with her.
She's number one women of all time.
Joan Rivers.
And then you got like the Paula
Poundstone is,
and you got like a Zamboni.
Roseanne Barr,
who's a crusher.
I just heard all the time,
deal with her on a random
fez the other day.
She,
you know what real deal.
She's my,
her and Joan Rivers man.
That's actually kind of close when you
think about that.
She's a beast.
We got to get Rosie.
She's fucking funny man.
She was in the eighties I remember.
She was funny.
Like the best guys in the world were
funny,
you know.
I mean she was a killer.
She didn't give off fuck and then when
they are gave her a TV show she gave
less fucks.
She's a
beast.
She was talking about how she like her
first show or first comedy show in La.
Like she had only been doing,
I think comedy like two years a lot.
Mitzi loved her and that,
that same show like our first night in
La.
Yeah.
Then she booked the tonight show in the
first night.
That is insane.
Insane.
We got to hit it on the page.
I talked to her like she was thinking
about stopping by or San Diego show in
comic con.
So you chat with
Oh cool.
Cool.
Well she follows me on Twitter.
Like she,
she asked me questions sometimes.
She's all in like new world order type
shit.
I'm actually meet with her having her
own podcast.
The amazing
tape it even if you can't watch it.
I did Rosie O'donnell show just to me.
Rosie.
I really did.
I think she's bad ass.
I like her whether I agree with what she
says about things or not.
I think Rosie's got some balls and she
doesn't seem like an asshole to me at
all.
They had that show on VH one with the
badge standup badge that the host quit
and Rosie took over.
That was when she was a strong ass woman
and the girl you like dog.
She ripped some some fucking stages too.
What's a chick on channel five every
day?
The one that seen me at the bus stop,
like the lesbian chick that singing on
the bus stop.
You went on his show the other day.
You were looking for tickets.
Oh,
you're talking about that chick Ellen
degenerate.
Yeah.
Mother fuckers that rip it up.
Paula Poundstone rip,
but chick from the comedy store,
the one that was in with the,
with them,
they smoked a joint with the chick with
the fucking big fits.
But Lily Tomlin,
she used to rip up the phone.
She had like a
one woman show.
But I,
I think,
you know,
in my opinion,
Sarah Silverman,
it's right up there.
I think she's at the top.
Let's go top ones of all time.
Rivers with a strong Roseanne kicking
the fuck.
I don't know man.
I might five Roseanne might've been
better.
Like has her delivery man.
No,
it's fucking hard.
Very hard because [inaudible] rivers is
still out there swinging.
So in my opinion,
like you got to give her a number one
cause she's still swinging.
You know,
she's still there doing
cards.
But when they asked her,
she was on the wrestler,
there's one of the funniest things.
He's pretty gangster.
He asked if she was in the wrestler.
I almost fucking died when I think,
um,
I think it's harder for a woman to do
stand up.
I'm always,
yes,
I think that men are sexist for the most
part.
And they don't want to listen to a woman
talk.
You know?
I think it's harder to get a lot of
men's attention and obviously that's a
big generalization because there's a lot
of Sarah Silverman fans from men are a
lot of women fans of comedy.
There are men,
I think.
Yeah,
featuring I cheer for women when they're
free trade and I love motherfuckers who
go on stage headlining and think they're
going to follow a woman on a Saturday
night.
Your shit better be tight because of
this chicken.
The size to go update goes her way.
Member,
that's half women.
Shit goes her way.
You're going to have a rough time and
I've seen it happen.
I've seen a buried motherfucker ego at
the store.
Don't fuck around with women sometimes.
I've seen sham attached very
motherfuckers in the yellow one.
Yeah,
I've seen her.
Barry motherfuckers in the,
Oh wow.
There's a lot of women who will take
that room and flip you.
They don't have titties.
I don't give a fuck.
They looked like they'd been fucked in
the ass a thousand times and they go
there with that attitude and you're
sitting there going,
wow,
what was the Puerto Rican chicken at the
store early on that married,
what's his name when you're talking
about,
but she had the kit with,
what's his name and she did a couple of
episodes and YPD blue and she was on her
way.
I saw her in that a couple of Tuesday
nights and I was like,
damn,
this bitch on the road for a few years
she had a kid,
but at the time she had the kid,
she'd sit the kid and the fucking bar at
the comedy store and go do 15 minutes.
I think I told you that like one of the
most promising sets of an open miker I
ever saw was Kelly curse.
Carsten.
Absolutely
Kelly,
Kirsten,
Kirsten.
Especially when she didn't have a
boyfriend and she's a sweetie and she,
you know,
she got a boyfriend,
she'd calm down.
But when she didn't have a boyfriend,
she was fucking angry.
And she did this bit,
man,
she did this bit.
Oh,
I wish I was a man.
You know Kelly's like I'm short.
I'm five,
eight and she's at least five inches
taller than me.
Right.
I mean how tall is she?
She's six one six two six.
It's a very tall girl and,
and she get fucking angry and she's like
real physical and like she would do,
she did this bit,
I wish I was a man.
If I was a man,
I'd come and checks and go,
fuck you have my kid.
She goes,
if I was a man,
she goes,
if I had a dick,
had Kiszko lazy that traffic and it's
like this really wild bit man.
Listen man,
I was at an open mic or she was an open
Mike or Rather,
I mean she was just starting out and I
was like,
wow.
I was like,
this chick is fucking strong or you show
it that the chicks that winter,
the comedy store either had a sit or get
off the fucking pot.
They only had about three or four weeks
to adjust to that style of comedy.
And you would see them go away on their
own because it's six guys before you,
and you got to go up there with your
quaint material.
At 10
45 we had about three or four those sets
until he got back to Mitzi.
So now what you had to do is go in there
and go,
you know what,
I gotta use my pussy and going and throw
some fucking heat,
grow some steam.
And that's either do or die at the
store.
Even Sherri Shepherd,
I remember Sherry Shepherd early.
Oh yeah.
Uh,
what was the cute black girl that had
the white boyfriend manager?
God dammit.
And then you have a man that was all
stitched up and plastic surgery it up
and shit that we're holding it together
with Krazy glue.
And I remember a comic that used to go
to the laugh factory.
She was asking me about the store,
like,
you know,
like when should I go up?
Like when is the crowd?
Like the nicest I've like just like
stops.
And this conversation right now,
you don't know what you're talking
about.
You're talking about chaos.
audible.com go to audible.
Go buy yourself some cool shit.
There's a lot of books and like I said,
Sarah Silverman's book and that's a good
one.
I'll go get that one.
Get it for free.
audible.com forward slash.
Joe,
do you know her manager?
Have you ever met Sarah Silverman?
Silverman's manager?
Which ones are manager lady who is
amazing and she was so fucking bad ass.
She just like coming up to guys and got
you better not fuck with Tony if you
fuck with Tony who was intense.
She was amazing.
What was that about?
Uh,
there,
uh,
I think Tony's managed managers were
there and so she just came up and
started like,
just,
she's just screaming at these two guys.
It was so awesome too.
And then I was like,
who?
Who was that girl?
I thought,
you know?
And he goes,
oh,
that sir.
So we're meant to manager.
I was like,
fuck,
that's bad ass.
She's a bad ass.
All right.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible]
dot com and we do have a new thing at on
it.
We have an orangutan kettlebell now the
orangutan kettle bell is a,
it's like 50 something pounds.
They did.
They insist on doing them in Pudong One
pooed in two pood.
It's pretty bad ass.
I said,
yeah,
so now we have the orangutan that goes
along with the chimp and the grill or
the rank time being the 1.5 pooed,
which I think is 50 52 pounds or
something like that,
or 50 pounds.
Why are you doing it with a pill?
I don't know why.
I don't know why they did that.
Like what is a pooed man?
It's like old piece of paper to show her
legit Bro.
Yeah.
I think we're really fucking up their
Aubrey.
Let's put the God damn weight to these
things and it's like fucking like kilos
and shit.
Yeah.
Why do we have to have inside fucking
secret shit?
I don't even know what a food is and I
sell these things.
Why don't you do it by ounces?
That would be cooler.
I work out with these bitches every day
and I don't know what a fucking pooed
is.
What's a pooed goddammit.
But what,
what they are is these primal bells.
Go to audible.com or on it doc fucking
krc.com,
a kettle bells audit.com,
forward slash kettlebells,
and you'll see the regular kettlebells,
which we,
uh,
we sell.
But the new ones are the primal bells.
And if you go to [inaudible] dot com
forward slash primal dash bells,
you'll see these.
And,
um,
that's the,
uh,
running a tank.
They're not as threatening looking.
They have like a big mushy phase.
Yeah.
The,
yeah.
It's cool.
None of the fact that I'm blade Erik
Griffin.
What's the name ever?
It's really amazing artwork too.
If you see it in with the black
contrast,
so you can see how really how good the
artwork is.
It's,
it's incredible.
I mean,
these,
uh,
these are some of the,
as far as like idea to,
uh,
to actual product when we came up with
this ideal and then like seeing them now
that did differences.
It's perfect.
The fucking gorillas.
Amazing man.
I can't help but look at that thing.
It's,
look at that Joey.
Look at that gorilla.
That shit's incredible.
Look at that thing.
Look at the fucking artwork on that.
It's looks like,
what the fuck?
It's so bad ass.
And they're really well balanced as well
as one of the most important things
about doing this.
A primal bell.
Things that we wanted to make sure that
if we had these gigantic kettlebells,
um,
we would,
even though they have this beautiful
artwork on them,
we wanted to make sure they're balanced.
What's the lightest one?
Way 35 pounds one pooed and that's why
there's one they had was 30 pounds,
35 pounds,
a 1.5,
which is whatever.
And uh,
and then there's the gorilla,
which is a two,
which is 70.
You think they are doing the food
because it's like monkey poop.
Yeah.
No,
cause they're being silly.
They're being silly.
They're debris.
And that's what it is.
And traditional Prob,
I don't even think about it until today.
It's Kazaam high.
Yeah.
It's fuck.
And I see things clearly when I'm really
high.
She thinks clearly it's very important.
Um,
yeah.
So anyway,
go there,
go there and check that shit out.
Have some,
uh,
can you show some hemp force protein?
Get yourself some,
uh,
all kinds of battle ropes and weight
vests and steel.
Maces anything you need as far as like
strength and conditioning.
If you're trying to tell people you
train UFC,
you your,
if she did shoot,
they do on all access.
It's me,
bro.
Look a fucking ropes in my yard.
I'm swinging around a maze.
It's like old school.
If we go back to sword fight and
unprepared,
we also sell buffalo bars.
They're called Tonka bars.
Didn't shit.
Says Delicious.
They're made the way the,
uh,
the,
native Americans used to make them as
well with these cranberries and buffalo
meat buffaloes.
Super good for you and delicious.
And Buffalo was a big,
so if you shoot him,
you're likely to hit him.
It's easier to farm them that way.
Joey Diaz bothering me
anyway on a.com.
Using code name rogue,
you'll save 10% off any and all
supplements on,
I need to say about this.
A orangutang thing.
Um,
we're going to,
uh,
we're donating money for each,
primal bell.
Uh,
each purchase donates $5 to save the red
ape.
Um,
so,
uh,
the,
is that a,
rang a tiny charity organization.
So whatever this organization is called,
that's unfair.
It's unclear here on this email.
I'll just read it what it says and
you'll,
uh,
we'll,
we'll figure it out together.
It says we launched the orangutan primal
bell and have linked it to an orangutan
charity organization.
Every purchase donates $5 to save the
red ape.
I don't if save the red ape is the name
of the organization or there's an
organization that's not named that's
unclear to me and that statement.
So I would just be clear about that.
But the idea is that every,
for every one of these orangutan
kettlebells,
we sell five bucks,
we'll go to a whatever this charity is.
So I guess her main tags are endangered.
They fucking weird looking man.
I mean,
they really do look like something out
of Avatar.
Look at that thing.
But that's a real animal.
How weird is that?
God dammit and intelligent looking thing
with this fucking crazy face.
Please stop.
Shut that off.
I don't want,
listen,
I don't want to focus on that.
Uh,
anyway.
rank tane kettle bells in on it.com.
Use the code name.
Rogan.
Save 10% off any and all supplements.
Joey Diaz is here,
ladies and gentleman.
That's right.
Socket started.
Here we go.
Experience
Joe Rogan podcast.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Joey motherfucking Diaz,
fresh off the road,
killing them in DC,
taking it nationwide.
Joey Diaz no longer stationary.
Constantly on the move.
Now,
no choice,
brother.
You're on the move.
And then we'll swing and we're going to
Milwaukee and I'm from sweet.
Got Him and get some good spaghetti,
a good Italian neighborhood over there.
[inaudible] man,
you're killing them with triam brother.
You know,
this was the plan 12 years ago and
finally,
you know,
it ain't no listen man.
When you get there and you put the work
in,
it becomes easy to,
and you're enjoying it.
Yeah.
You just can't wait to fucking stay.
You can't wait to go out and try that
new joke anymore.
That new delivery.
You know,
you're a black belt one comedy.
Yeah.
It's a fun thing to do now.
Yeah,
very fun.
You know?
Uh,
it's funny because I went from the two
fucking tremendous shows we did in
Boston,
which has your basic listen man.
You don't ever want to bombing Boston.
No.
That's the end of everything.
And that's Arrow Smith.
That's,
that's Dane Cook.
That's a lot of fun.
Lenny Clarke,
there's so much tradition.
I remember the first time I played in
dope to me,
I went to the store that like,
uh,
all those guys from Boston.
What was the car?
The taekwondo.
Got It all.
So I had sleep apnea or you leave the
triggers.
I don't know.
The comedians from Boston,
he had long hair and he'd play a guy
right there.
Oh God.
Dammit man.
Those guys,
what the fuck is his name?
Oh my God,
he's going to kill me.
I'm sorry.
Dossier.
They will all your buddies.
And they were like,
don't give a play Boston.
I'm like,
Nah,
but like,
we'll get you in this way.
We got me into the comedy connection.
I'm on days.
The open mic with the kid who died,
Kevin Fitzgerald or whatever his name
was,
Kevin Fitzgerald and Denver.
Kevin.
He was friends with our friend Maguire.
We've been mutual buddy.
He died of cancer I hope.
And Kevin Knox on Mondays.
They introduced me to him.
So I became a part of this thing I would
do and Dover the WHO and I was never
good enough to play Boston.
I would get to do the collection on
Monday nights.
And that's like having a fucking
striping comedy when you get to play
Boston and they accept you into that.
Yeah.
So I knew before I went to Boston that
we got to,
this money sets is like good to tighten
my shit up.
We didn't go to Boston unprepared.
It was me.
You went to hurry,
you know?
I mean it was just a fucking perfect
night.
It was funny how the next day I had to
go to a summer jam up in San Jose with
Russell Peters,
who was a pleasure to fuck him.
See and Angela Johnson and all those
guys and I didn't really get across.
I wish I was burnt out from the Boston
shows.
Like I put all the energy I had close to
fucking shows the will feet,
which was great.
It was a great thing that I left and
Charleston and one in Fox,
one fucking sports,
the whole thing.
The dude's name was dumb,
wasn't it?
Hit me.
What was his last name?
Dammit.
It's trying to be crazy.
Dominic.
He just hit me up and you up about sleep
apnea.
He wanted to go take a test about a year
ago.
I can't believe,
I can't remember his name.
I ran out of room.
Granted,
[inaudible] name's John.
No,
it's no disrespect to understand that
the attorney,
that was the,
the,
the Dominic fig.
Dominic fig.
What was,
what was the nice gate kid so worried.
I was going to not remember this.
A nice gate kid that went to Chris
Mcguire,
his house that he'd done it and your
name came up and there was two gay guys
at the table and they go,
he doesn't like Joe Rogan.
He goes,
why not?
he called Princess Diana [inaudible].
They all went,
oh my God.
It was horrible.
That's hilarious.
Those were great times when those guys
from Boston took me and they would take
me up there.
So then I went to San Jose,
then I went to DC and that was really
the first time I used to do like
headliners and Tysons corner for years I
used to fly into Dallas.
This is the first time I was in the city
and it was an experience because I tell
you what,
if I would've gone five years ago,
guys that would have bombed this
weekend.
Really?
Why you say that?
Because I learned how to control more.
You know,
you learn and calm.
it's so funny how we put ourselves out
there where you never did.
I didn't have a choice.
They were telling me to ask me the
headline.
I would go up there with stupid fucking
jokes and you would headline and you'd
have the time,
but you really,
you weren't really a headliner.
And it's true when people start to come
to see you,
it makes you work a little harder.
Like every time you see him you want to
have new material or new float floaty.
So I had never been there and I,
and I sharpened up this week and I went
there and I tell you they were very
politically correct.
The city of DC downtown.
Hey man,
it's a nation's fucking capital.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm talking about weed and it might not
suit,
you know,
you can't do that.
They took the ride and as far as the
club,
the fucking VCM private tests,
the staff,
the fucking,
the Spanish bud tenders.
I mean the whole fucking deal.
It's just a great little club.
I had the Burrito one night,
just the whole experience.
The city of Washington DC,
I had the best chicken Teriyaki and
white tuna.
I've had the last 20 fucking years.
I've done the theaters there before,
um,
like a couple of different times,
but I never did the improv before.
Recently I did it with Callan.
Yeah.
I just stopped going back.
Let's go for a week.
Three nights.
Yeah.
I get to what their you want to go back
there?
Yeah.
Let's go back and gave play a lot of
good people there.
I went to a lot of places.
Yeah.
With death squad usually doesn't go.
I tell you what place really blew my
fucking mind.
Who?
They're ready to kill people.
Salt Lake City.
The Mormons are ready dog.
They ain't fucking around.
Uh,
Louisville,
Kentucky.
They're ready.
They'll come down.
No,
I went to Lexington,
the Homo University in Kentucky.
Great son.
I had a great time of going to these
places that were odd ball,
but I wanted to see what was out there,
who I was listening to the fucking pot
people were driving six,
seven hours.
People driving the Louisville place.
Tremendous.
Yeah.
With Trisha Gura.
No Dunkin.
Tremendous.
Maybe I did it with cigarette too.
Yeah.
It's a good way to do it twice.
I think I did one night in a weekend or
something like that.
Going back to Nashville this year.
I can't wait.
Oh,
Nashville.
Is he Utah are really that crazy.
Like it was,
I mean,
like are people crazy out there?
I mean like that people that come in,
I'm thinking that what you mean is like,
are they like crazy Mormon?
Yeah.
Did they already there?
But that's more so,
do you see this map?
It's kind of like what you've talked
about.
It's a,
of all the porn searches that they just
released,
porn hub did it.
And of course what you used to always
say the south,
uh,
Ebony Ebony,
but uh,
Utah Blank and somebody's,
uh,
people are saying it's because child
porn is the number one search.
Well,
you paused and you taught is blank.
That's weird.
It's like one of the few states where
there's no downloads porn for,
right.
Wow.
Look at Maine.
Look at,
look at it like Vermont.
Yeah.
Just gave up Asian California.
Uh,
W I don't know why I need a queen is do
you know I didn't need a queen is never
even heard of that.
What is this website that you're going
to Gizmodo and it's based off a
statistics given by porn hub.
Cream pie is Florida teen is Texas.
That noise.
You're not hearing that?
Yeah.
Here's some crazy feedback.
Uh,
my cream pie was a lot more popular than
I imagined,
but a cream pies like number one.
Yeah,
I think cream pies probably number one.
And teens probably because people are to
come in.
The people that clean patch?
No.
Like most,
most of them are cream pies.
Well that's what people like to think.
Let me look at this.
You need to fuck it.
I don't know what the map looks like.
You know,
I guess I've heard that Al Franken can
draw the map like you get get al Franken
up to a chalkboard and he could just
draw the map for you.
And I was kind of like sad cause I was
like um,
I can't I get it.
Yeah,
I'd have no idea where I'm looking at
these things.
Okay.
Cause it's just cream pie.
Cream Pie.
Like,
like listing taxes is teen,
which is fucking creepy man.
That shit's creepy.
Ohio's MILF cream pie.
So I not just cream pie.
It's old cream pie.
Yeah.
This,
this is weird man.
It's weird how California is dominated
by Asian.
Look at that number one Asian boom
headed the times and the average visits,
why don't understand that.
Do you get that average number of
visits,
duration,
the duration,
the average for the people in
California.
It was like on the darker end,
but not as dark as fucking like look at
Georgia and it's teen ebony has the
longest going to a store and say I want
two kids.
Fucking,
it's like,
no,
they're like 18 or 19 or something like
that.
And that's the idea going into it and
get like Asian porn,
like a white dude fuck of a Chinese
chicken.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Cause she'd just say that's impossible.
But it's just like so standard.
There's,
it's weird how there's like standard
like categories of porn,
you know,
like DP,
like that's a category.
What's the DP?
Double Penetration.
That's like normal little,
we're like ones in the ass,
ones in the vagina.
It's so passe.
It's so passe that it's a,
it's its own category.
It's like gosh,
it's not just one,
not just a couple of crazy people got
together and one of the vagina.
Yeah,
double pantries.
Right?
Gay.
Listen,
if you're a chick and you love Dick,
tell me,
that wouldn't be amazing.
The problem is that it's on video and
everyone's gonna know.
But,
but the reality,
if you're a girl,
if you like anal sex,
I don't know if girls like that,
but if you do like it and then you're
like me,
it's,
it varies.
But if you do like it and you lock it in
your box as well,
I mean take away society standards and
that would be like super awesome if you
had like Ashton Kutcher and your butt
and Brad Pitt and your box mean if you
were a gal,
you'd be so happy,
but it would be like,
you know Ashley and get out of there.
You're gobbling it all.
That saved me.
So why would you want,
that's not what we didn't you write out
Brad Pitt in there?
Why are you sharing it with Ashton?
Well,
because you're a freak and you want it
all.
She has no limitations to a freak.
I have no idea what this is.
I need a porn is like when it,
when I can buy Google like that.
Once a state was a
Nevada,
it's just a need.
A queen is what the car kind of porn is
called.
I can't figure out what it is.
Need a queen.
What?
Did you understand?
A word of what you're saying.
All right,
so,
so like a c here,
this,
uh,
Asian is California and need a queen.
Is that,
oh,
that's the style of style porn.
Yeah.
And when I look it up,
it looks like it's like pageant porn or
something.
Oh,
that actually is interesting.
If that was a category of like you've
won the pageant and soccer.
Did you dirty bitch?
Like,
yeah.
You've got the queen.
You took down the number one gal.
No,
that's a weird thing,
isn't it?
That's weird.
What Todd to categories are weird,
like fit.
Some dude's like only jerk off to anal.
It just like they can't wait.
She's more but born.
You put,
well,
you,
it's bows to woo.
You know,
like what the fuck man.
It's,
it's weird how that's actually a,
your category.
Yeah.
I find myself going into a weird
categories a lot lately just to mix it
up.
Kind of like when you drink the same
alcohol for so long,
you're like,
I'm gonna try something different.
I've been like black chicks getting
fucked by big white.
Is there a lot
of that?
Yeah,
there's tons of that.
So black chase getting dominated by
white guys with big decks.
Yeah,
huge days.
So it's like some like he like this
black guy.
Yeah.
You face body and my giant white picker.
And then have half of them sprint to the
girl.
How about that?
The first guy who gets there,
it gets to Fucker,
it'd be a bunch of white guys jacking
off.
Come on,
come on.
Come on.
Black.
Did you hear this?
The sex industry closed down because of
AIDS again.
Yeah.
Again,
here and the chick that,
that,
that Boehner Guy,
uh,
that chicken out.
We did a porn with wiener.
We,
Anthony Wiener politicians.
Yeah.
She uh,
actually,
uh,
did a movie with a guy that I read that
she did well,
the guy was exposed to HIV.
He had sex with the girl who had
contacted HIV.
He had sex with her.
But allegedly from what I've read,
it's not that easy to transmit from HIV,
from a woman to a man that it's much
easier for a man to a woman because of
the man and checks fluids into the body.
So I don't know if that's true though.
Obviously I'm not a doctor,
but like a Tommy Morrison is a,
supposedly it really sick with AIDS now.
Like he has full blown aids and they did
a story about it recently.
Somebody posted it on the underground
and it was really fucking sad.
I mean he's dying.
He's on like life support system
essentially.
He has full blown aids,
you know,
and he,
they say he got it from a girl,
you know,
I mean I,
it might be possible.
I do not know.
You know,
I've heard like obviously that's what
you always hear.
It's not possible for a guy to get it
from a girl.
You always hear that.
But I don't know if that's anything
else.
I'll let you put it.
It got it from a needle.
He could've got it from an email.
That's the obvious fucking choice.
Well,
we were talking about that a,
yesterday we thought Dwayne Twain
Ludwig,
we were talking about fighters and pills
and a pain relief and you know,
fucking would leave relieves pain better
than heroin.
I mean,
he's right.
Anything,
right?
So for a lot of fighters they might've
started shooting up because the,
the heroin,
like relieving the pain for them was a,
was so effective.
Look,
I don't want to do it that way.
Those opiates,
that's what it's,
that's what it's about.
Getting Houston needles in general.
Well,
you know what,
if you're a fighter and you know you're
used to getting punched in the face,
get your face stitched up and just,
that's like needles not gonna Freak you
out when stitches put your nose back
together in the second round and you're
going back out there to fight of other
two fucking rounds at three fucking
round.
Yeah.
You just fucking five rounds with Ray
Mercer and Kod into the ropes like he
did.
Did you ever see that with Tommy
Morrison?
Getting knocked out by Ray Marshall is
one of the most frightening knockouts
I've ever seen in my life because,
well,
first of all it's frightening because
Ray Marshall was a murderous puncher,
but it was hilarious for me because I
had this friend that would always root
for white guys.
It was fucking,
oh he would,
he wanted white guys to win boxing
ranches so bad.
He never wanted it to be the best
fighter.
He always wanted it to be white fighter.
So like he rooted for Cherry Cooney and
so he got hit here and Raymar so just
unloads on him.
Yeah,
and it's,
it's who gets caught in the ropes
though.
Look at this.
Like he's caught in the robes and ray
Mars is teeing off them.
That's terrible qualities is a better
quality version that we could see it
smooth because it was real so choppy.
But anyway,
the,
it was a frightening,
frightening knock out.
But once you've done that,
you could shoot heroin.
That's 235 PA listen pro that that once
you have that pain and that pain doesn't
fucking go away and that little needle
knocks it away.
Listen to all those people stories.
That's how it started and that was
started launching the rookies behind you
to take your fucking job in football.
You just bought you a fucking girl,
a house and a boat.
Yeah,
and you bought your parents a boat and
now you're 28 and a 22 year old.
All American is coming in in front of
you and you got a bit,
a little bit of knee pain and if you
complain about it then you have surgery
and you out and then this motherfucker
steals your job.
Are you going to do,
you ain't got time.
You're doing what you need to do.
Shoot to cortisone,
shoot the fucking shoot the Mecca shoot
at all.
I don't give a fuck as long as I play.
At the end of the season we'll talk
about surgery and guts.
What dog?
At the end of the surgery,
they meet a fucking guru who says,
you don't need surgery.
We're going to shoot this thing again
and that's it.
Ray Mercer was a fucking murderous
puncher back then.
Watching that right there.
Right there,
dude.
All of them.
Yeah,
the one the left,
it stiffened them and the right to put
them down and then he hit him two more
times.
Full clip after that.
Watch that one more time just to
finishing blows.
Cause I'm sear is one of the most
devastating knockouts I've ever seen.
Man.
If you saw this on TV,
when was this?
Seventies late seventies early eighties
eighties yeah.
Here's that right hand and brain.
Mercer was a fucking killer and he could
take it to man.
Ray could take it like these shots,
right?
Bang,
boom,
Bam,
Bam.
And two more before he goes down.
Look how many times he fucking hates
him.
Those bunches though,
isn't it?
Well she not even joking though.
It might have,
that was it.
He just got A's.
I mean you didn't get braid them free
thing,
but who knows how he got it.
But it ate Sushi that afternoon and that
night
could not,
it's
not good for your health.
No,
that fucked him up.
That was it.
They did the movie with Stallone when he
was done,
but yeah.
You know,
there's some sort of a,
uh,
he did.
The movie was just alone after that,
didn't they?
Before?
After that?
I think it was before that check.
Before that.
Right.
I just sent them over to fucking time.
I was like,
give it a Puerto Rican and check on the
fifth handle.
What's that?
Too early,
right?
Yes.
Yeah.
No.
They sent him over the top though.
Could you imagine being a fucking guy
who gets to play Tommy Gun back in the
day he brought,
I mean,
how do you,
how does anybody want to fill out both?
You're a young black guy that rocky took
in with a fucker.
He was,
it was a horrible fucking,
what was the guy that,
what was the black guy in that movie?
Who's the big black guy that did all
those movies that did it?
Who was a Tyson's manager that robbed
them?
Don King.
Remember the Don King Him in that movie.
He was the worst.
Come on Tom.
Tommy,
come with me and the limo.
We got white women.
Tommy just got punched in the head with
Ray Mercer.
What are you going to do?
You're going to stand there next to
Sylvester.
Fuck no,
no.
I think he was doing blow in the limo.
Get that scene up.
Get that scene up and he's doing blow in
the limos.
She's got those little white milky
Teddy's.
He's going to fucking bananas.
Rocky's like,
what about when they taught you?
Fuck you bitches.
Bang.
It must be incredibly hard to keep your
motivation to be a fighter when that
happens.
It's a fighter that's like the opposite
world of being a fighter.
Like you're in a gigantic blockbuster.
You have rocky movie back when it means
something to be in a rocky movie.
If you didn't like rocky,
not rocky today.
Did you see Rocky Bob?
Hey man,
if you're in the rocky movies,
just not bad.
Sit Right.
The final scene,
it's rocky and the white chick.
Oh,
this is grades in Spanish.
Tammy Morrison him square up and is the
Shitty don king.
Biggest smallest headers.
Oh,
rocky punched him a bunch of times to
the back of the head.
Wow.
And knocked him down.
Tommy's really upset.
Oh Wow.
He's through them.
And rocky hit him on the way in.
Incredible fight here.
Wow.
Rocky took his legs out.
He's going to MMA no ground and
Oh,
now Tommy's coming back.
Boy,
that looks fake.
Holy Shit.
That looks fake.
They looked so fake.
It should be illegal.
They gave him 20 million.
That's how fucking face.
Oh Man.
The next fifth go rub it.
Oh,
he probably made at least 20 million.
If you're in this moment is a huge
movie,
man.
Look this and use the finish high one
giant left Hook and Don King,
Don King
hit me out.
Sue You.
So that's a digital signal that we're
allowed to use the Spanish version for.
Yeah,
we can get away with that.
Yeah.
You just got to get the brain.
Sorry.
I found the map of the U S and I didn't
know where a lot of shit was.
I didn't know where La Shit was in,
in the,
uh,
in the weird areas like the Maine and
New Hampshire areas.
A whole Joe Rogan looking at me.
Don't look at me.
Quit.
What's the six states in New England,
New Hampshire,
Connecticut,
Rhode Island.
Vermont,
Massachusetts.
That's it.
What island?
Connecticut.
Molly from Maine that may put Maine.
I forgot Maine.
I Dunno.
Is Maine New England?
It must be.
Yeah.
It means means got to be New England.
Yeah,
I forgot that.
And New Hampshire's New England to know.
Yes sir.
Well,
it doesn't hurt states,
cities.
How dare you go.
Hampshire is,
but you don't know.
You really are a baby lamb sheets where
you don't live close to boast.
If you don't live in most of the Boston,
you flying through New Hampshire.
Yeah.
In the fucking flights.
I dirt cheap.
It's like two different fucking world's
to fly into New Hampshire at the flying
into Boston at 45 minutes.
Like Burbank,
lax,
New Hampshire's filled with a lot of
fucking people that don't want to hear
the government's bullshit.
They're all like those live free or die
folks.
They,
you know,
they have compounds set up that's on
their license plate live free or die.
That's a gangster state.
You know they're like up there to where
you got to like shoot Moose to stay
alive when you're north of Boston.
You're a silly bitch.
Okay,
what I,
that's what,
that's not cold enough for you.
You need to go further because when we
would do gigs in Maine I'd be like,
oh my God,
it's colder.
We'd be in Boston and we'd go to Maine
to do a Gig.
December,
it'll be 10 degrees called you get out
of the car yard.
You can't believe these motherfuckers
live where it's colder than where we
live.
You have a bit of somewhere where you
look up and he'd go,
how the fuck do people live here?
And you make like a mental note.
Like this is the coldest I've ever been.
January 5th,
1990 fucking five they took me up from
Denver,
Colorado was living in boulder to do a
Gig in Cheyenne,
Wyoming,
Joe Rogan Shit and had it be 35 fucking
below with the windshield.
I left the hotel and I asked the guy at
the fucking thing,
where do you get something to eat?
And he looked at me and he goes,
maybe 50 yards down,
but I wouldn't leave if I was you.
I looked at him like,
bitch.
And I went out there and started walking
and like 25 minutes in,
I was like,
it's too cold to walk there.
And if I get to it,
it's going to definitely be cold to come
back.
Wow.
Like that's how I walk.
And I had chili and I mean it was
horrendous.
Had to take your jacket off and that I
sit next to the heater and that's,
that was something that,
uh,
we forget about that we don't have to
deal with that shit here.
$350.
I got for that gate as a feature act for
four shows.
That's a good gig in those days.
Yes.
That's a good gig.
It was.
I remember the,
uh,
I just got an email from John Schuler.
I gotta I gotta email them back.
I just remembered,
but I should do a lot of Schuler gigs,
you know,
and they varied.
You know,
like if,
if you've got a good one,
it was a couple hundred bucks,
maybe more,
you know,
depending on what kind of bar you set
up.
Those were great kids,
you know,
who'd like to have and some of them,
some of them were really,
they had a lot of them.
Schuller had a lot of them in
Connecticut that were great fucking
gigs.
Brown,
what is it called?
Brown Thompson.
Is that what it is?
Goddammit place in Hartford.
He used to have,
that was like our really good comedy
club.
It was,
he,
it was the only place in Hartford
because at the time I think there's an
Improv in Hartford,
Connecticut.
Now finally bunk.
A funny,
but yeah,
there wasn't any back in the day.
I want to say it was called Brown
Thompson.
It was like a bar.
And uh,
they used to,
they used to book the comedy there and
it was like a fucking comedy club.
It was like a real club.
It was a great gig.
Like people get excited about that Gig.
It was a good one.
She had them all over the place.
Two places where I thought I could
possibly get killed doing comment.
Craig Colorado is heavy fucking duty
Colorado.
That was the first time ever.
I got it.
I then them,
uh,
what do you call that shit when you get
the paperwork on the Gig and it said,
it said room is known to be active.
If anything happens,
run to your room and contact the bar
manager.
Like that's what it said of the triple
aim.
And the other crazy Gig I did was a
place call these civilizations.
These cities had been taken over by the
cities and they didn't give a fuck.
It was called Rock Springs,
Wyoming,
rock springs,
Wyoming.
They had done a thing on 60 minutes
about rock springs,
how the mob had taken over rock springs,
Wyoming.
And that's where they took wounded
hookers from Las Vegas and revamping the
fish.
They're pussies made a hook,
small time.
And that the Strip club day,
it was like AAA.
I'm not kidding you,
this dog.
This was a look it up.
Rock Springs,
Wyoming,
60 minutes.
The feds had a goal in and take it back
from the local fucking government.
This is craziness.
This shit,
they have gambling stuff and uh,
Mike,
well,
what's his name?
Like two of the guys from 60 minutes on
up there and did a report about it.
There's some crazy fucking places out
there that you'll never know about
unless you drive through.
I just got an email from a fucking great
guy that said he has a room in billings.
Meiomi a Montana,
a 400 seat little theater,
and he sent me an email.
I'm thinking about going up there
obviously like I'm fucking may because
that's the only month it's fucking warm
up there.
There's a website called rock spring
hookers.
Oh No,
no,
they don't.
Fuck,
but that's not rock splinters.
Meiomi hookers.net.
There you go.
Dog Dental.
Fuck around there.
It's to a different level.
That's what wounded hookers goal.
They get rehabbed.
The fixed the monkey.
How did they get rid of the committee
and the HIV rate?
Mercy takes care of him.
Punched him,
pull it up.
Don't pull it out.
Fine.
Don't put it up here.
No,
you can't do that.
What's that?
The website is a bad shit.
And I mentioned the name of it anyway.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Who gives a fuck boy black fault.
No,
no.
It's almost disgusting.
Yes and no.
And I don't want you to pull it.
The breweries is thinking,
I don't think we should rack Mac.
I mean it's an illegal business.
They're gonna get in trouble.
I don't want him to get in trouble
said,
but look at the interview.
But how do you find them?
Look at the intercom for
60 minutes.
60 minutes,
Rock Springs,
Wyoming,
1992 93 fucking I if it's the same damn
fig.
But you know we were talking about dom
fig,
the vampire comic.
Look at this.
There's a guy named dom fig that took
this fucking picture of a wave hitting
the buildings in Connecticut.
Holy Shit Man.
Look at this.
This was when sandy hit Brian.
See that show shit.
Pull that picture up.
It's a food photographer.
Austrac after catching a wave.
This is an incredible picture.
It's incredible because like the idea
that he was there while this actually
happened,
like you shouldn't be anywhere fucking
near there and this crazy assholes,
not just there.
He's taking pictures.
Photographer awestruck after catching a
wave is the title.
Yeah,
this is nuts,
man.
Did you find it?
Okay,
go to see post.com
or just look up dom fig comic and then
click on the third link in the see
Dominic dom,
Dominic fig comic Dominic fig comic and
then look under the third picture
Dominic fig comic and look under the
third link.
Rather it'll say Connecticut post.
Okay,
here we go.
Look at this fucking picture,
man.
This is insane.
I mean it's insane.
It's like what?
What were they thinking?
Building houses there.
First of all,
that's like beautiful for most of the
time,
but fuck man,
if there's a possibility,
but it didn't matter if you were right
in front of the water with this
motherfucker,
right?
Like they went like several blocks in
just destroying everything in its path.
It's like we're so crazy to think that
the oceans are going to stay where it
is.
What did nutty idea to like build
expensive shit right next to the edge.
Like tennis.
The edge is right here.
This is my spot.
Fucking,
I've got marked it off.
This is my house I got,
I'm up on stilts and only put the house
right right at the water.
And like the gamble is like,
how long is the water going to be there?
Is it going to stay there for a hundred
years?
Going to stay for 50 years?
What's the gamble?
You know?
And everybody's willing to take that
gamble because if you can open up your
window and you're there on the ocean,
like it's boat,
that's fucking amazing.
You know?
So they take that gamble parked that
bitch right next to the rocks and the
hope that nothing melts.
Yeah,
but you'd have a bigger gamble having a
house on a mountain like,
like with the fires that you had.
That's true.
Well,
eight fires are everywhere in
California.
I mean,
I talked to a firefighter that said
there's a real worry and not of if,
but when the one day one of these
motherfucker wildfires that they get is
going to catch La and the wind's going
be just right and he
said it's gonna burn right to the beach.
I go,
you think it will burn down Hollywood?
He goes,
I don't think we can stop it.
if you're dealing with the kind of fire
that can go that far and is is that
strong and it's wind aided and it's just
big enough cause fires can be really,
really,
really fucking big.
You know it's hard to wrap your head
around how big they can be,
but they can be so big that you can't
fucking control them.
All you do is try to contain them,
but you can't control them.
And if they get that big and they can't
cut it off in time and it starts going
towards La,
if it's the right time of year,
the right amount of Santa Ana winds
kicking in.
Shit man,
look what happened last year in New
Jersey.
I think it happened.
Could good happening right now in
Montana.
Like there's the pdf in Phoenix or in
Arizona rather
with Gusto.
And somebody told me they were driving
back from Vegas on Sunday and it was
fucking scary as shit all over the world
took a mate and a half hours to get home
with a man to when the shit and listen,
that's gonna.
Everything's getting more extreme.
Everything's getting more fucking
extreme brother.
The heat's getting more extreme.
Cold is getting more extreme.
And you know,
I'm not fucking Hell Gore.
I'm not gonna sit here and tell you
you're not shit.
No,
I thought it was over.
You didn't know.
You know,
I don't know what the fuck's going on,
but we evolve.
So that means the weather has to fucking
evolve.
And you know,
20 years ago I remember being in Jersey,
hanging out,
playing wiffle ball and what did it,
three minutes it would get dark dog and
all of a sudden have these chunks of
fucking hail would come out.
You know,
but look at now.
Now I went to the shore 80 times,
80 fucking thousands of times and went
to that Jersey shore asked me,
but I think that it would dissipate.
Like the way sandy came up and you know
what?
In three years,
guess what?
There's going to be another one,
Jack.
You know those people we see every year.
I have a tornado.
I ain't leaving.
People make a thousand jokes about
that's going to be South Jersey and
fucking three years it'd be three.
It's going to be every seven or eight
years.
Then it's going to go down and fucking
every four years and then 50 years from
now it'll be every fucking it.
You know that just the way it is.
We evolved,
man though everything moves.
Don't they find those dinosaur bones and
Montana.
Then you write that and then they belong
to facial,
sea bass or whatever the fuck it was.
Well,
there was a Greg and western and see
there.
They used to be a fucking interior
ocean.
The thing that's always stuck me about
boulder was the devil's thumb.
When you're on baseline and you're
driving close to university in the South
Boulder and you look to your right and
there's a thing that pops out of the
fucking mountain.
This,
this,
just this figure.
I had to look it up.
Boulder,
Colorado at Devil's thumb and it pops
up.
It makes you fucking think.
It makes you fun.
You know,
it's the weirdest thing.
I hiked up there one time was my dog.
Uh,
Hercule.
Yeah.
Hercules went up there and was missing
for a night and I went up there and
fucking tried to look them down.
They got snakes up there,
the whole thing.
But it makes you think,
what the fuck was here 3 million years
ago,
not me.
So I don't know.
I don't have to be answered.
Did y'all look at the devil stump?
Yeah.
Come on.
No,
I'm bald.
Right damn baseline.
When you drive and look at that fucking
thing,
that's a beautiful thing.
Did you hear about the kid in Minnesota
that got bitten by a wolf?
Yes.
Wolf fit him in his fucking head while
he's sleeping and wouldn't let cow wolf
was trying to eat him.
He was sleeping outside the tent and a,
I guess you don't know why it was other
people in the tent.
I don't know what the whole story was,
but the wolf clamp to hold of his
fucking head and wouldn't let go.
He imagine what a terrifying feeling it
is.
When a wolf,
a 75 pound wolf has clamped a hold of
your head while you're sleeping.
And this is the,
uh,
the first known attack,
in that state's history that they have
like documented.
I thought,
fuck is sharks biting people more,
more.
We fucking today,
dude,
I was in Hawaii and they bit too fucking
people while I was there.
One of them died.
He's serious.
Yeah.
They get one kid got bit and his leg,
he was surfing and he got bit and
another woman got her arm bit off and
she died and kid live.
The boy lived because his friends,
uh,
tied his leg off of the tourniquet and
brought him into the,
um,
into the hospital like really quickly.
Yeah,
they used a,
um,
uh,
like a leash.
I think I got like a lease for a Surf
Board and they,
uh,
they tied off his leg and tourniquet and
pulled him out of the water,
but they saw him,
they saw him get attacked by the shark,
bit them in the leg.
It's tiger sharks apparently.
And they're trying to figure out now
like the people in Hawaii are,
they're going to do some studies now,
they to try to figure out why these
tiger sharks being more aggressive.
But there's,
there's,
there's going to be a lot of issues with
wildlife in the ocean as well because
these predators don't have as much to
eat because we've fished so much.
We take so much tuna and so many
different fish that they survive off of.
Like,
I would imagine that a lot of fish are
going to be in real trouble,
like the fish that also rely on the fish
that we eat because we fucking kill
everything man.
And all the fish has that fucking shit
in it right now from Tokyo.
I've been seeing all that.
Yeah,
there's a 3% increase.
I think they said in the amount of
radiation that,
uh,
they,
they've found in fish,
which is not not worrisome as far as
like health.
Apparently you can get away with a
little bit,
but the,
the,
the worry is that this could get worse.
Yeah.
You see that radiation chart where it
just shows like in like 15 years,
we're all pretty much fucked.
Fuck is Shiva is fucking crazy.
Yeah.
That's a scary,
scary situation.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's a much more scary than it's been,
you know,
like,
oh my God.
Did you see when Miley Cyrus did on TV,
she stuck her tongue out and showed her.
But meanwhile there's a fucking hole in
the earth that's filled with radioactive
shit and it's leaking into the ocean.
I mean,
it's really scary.
There's,
they can't stop it.
They can't contain it and they don't
know what the fuck to do.
And instead we're looking at Syria and
we're looking at all these other women.
Maybe there's threats.
I mean maybe,
maybe serious someplace we really do
need to be,
maybe they are using chemical weapons
but for sure that shit is going down to
Fukushima far fucking shore.
There's a real problem there and tepco
doesn't know what the fuck to do and no
one in the world has a solution for it.
I mean I don't,
I don't
know what the hell they're going to do.
I mean it's just constantly leaking
radioactive waste and what are the
people in Tokyo,
what's that going to be like in a
decade?
You know what,
what it means it's right down the hill
from that fucking place.
I mean what is,
what is,
what is going to happen?
What is,
are they going to have any like non
radioactive fish and don't they rely on
fish?
Like there's a huge amount of their
income and their,
their diet that relies on fish.
That's going to be a terrible place.
It can be a real issue.
You know they're finding radioactive
bunny's like bunnies that have
deformities and shit that live there.
They're born with no ears.
It's like all sorts of weird shit going
on
down near there.
Yeah.
What if the fish start turning into
like,
like these tiger sharks are eating these
radiate,
you know,
these fish and stuff and it's in the
water and it starts becoming what?
Like a Zombie sharp NATO.
I mean like,
that's like real,
you know,
like
listen,
speaking and imagine that used in court
against you.
I mean like these bits are going to
these physical imagine like you trying
to argue that you're smart and then
like,
okay,
no,
that's real.
It's like fish shark Nedo Zombie fish
shark nail.
The,
if the fish become like some Newton kind
of animals that,
yeah.
Well the,
you know,
that could happen.
Mean I don't think that's really how
things me tell you the life isn't a
fucking comic books on,
but yeah,
and a comic book that would become
Godzilla.
It'd become the,
uh,
the creature from the black lagoon or
some shit.
He thought it was Maine.
No,
no.
Godzilla was a creation because of the
atomic bomb.
Supposedly they the uh,
the US dropped atomic bombs on Japan and
then Godzilla was born because the
radiation,
like all those animals,
those giant animals Mothra all that
shit.
Rodin,
I believe wrote made me Rodin was from
space coming true.
Well that was the idea.
No,
it's not coming true.
Just some fucking sharks bit.
Some people,
those are good movies that you saw the
string and it fuck your world up.
You'll be safe from the MOTHRA string.
Yeah.
The matras string is shit.
Why
bad today?
ABC would do monster week at four 30,
the afterschool movie,
four 30 after dark shadows.
You grew some fucking eat jack.
Pull up some videos of got Zillow,
Zillow versus the smog monster who the
baddest one was Godzilla vs the smog
months.
You Marilyn's King Kong versus Godzilla.
They had to make King Kong the same size
and that was though,
it's very disappointing to me when I was
boy that I found out how much smaller
King Kong was and Godzilla,
it wasn't even close.
Got Dental.
It's like 500 feet high.
King Kong's 50 feet high,
50 feet high ain't shit.
When you're dealing with Godzilla,
but in Godzilla versus King Kong all
sudden King Kong is huge.
That's a good little fucking jam too.
Oh,
Godzilla.
Tokyo.
Yeah,
those blue oyster cult,
right?
Yeah.
Look,
the smoke wakes him up.
Those movies were so,
people today can't understand how
awesome those movies are.
Oh No.
People don't understand how amazing
these movies were.
Amazing.
It's La versus Tokyo spreading bad.
This is,
this is incredible.
That's when he became the smog monster
and he flies around just blowing
poisoned smog on people.
Kim trails.
Breath.
Yeah.
He was original chem trail.
The smog monster.
Look,
everybody look how bad the fucking
special effects are.
I'm like,
God,
it's amazing.
Oh,
so good.
What people don't understand
when you were a kid or when I was a kid
rather,
and we would watch this.
We would have to be wooed at you.
You were,
you had to suspend disbelief.
You were just amazed that they could
show you any visual representation of a
gigantic lizard,
like anything that remotely looked like
it,
you were willing to accept,
like,
look at that.
Look how bad that is.
But we were willing to accept it because
we knew that up until then,
like there was stress that was the best
was the best.
That was it.
If you go to the original King Kong and
the original King Kong,
the differences in the way the Japanese
did it in the way of Ray Harryhausen did
it.
Um,
I think it was ray Harryhausen.
I might've made that up,
but uh,
the animator,
they used to do it frame by frame.
They would,
they would just move the clay a little,
took a picture,
move the clay,
a little,
take a picture of moving to clay.
A little,
took a picture.
It took fucking forever.
But they would have these elaborate
fight scenes with these clay animals
that they created.
So He'd like King Kong fighting against
dinosaurs.
That shit took forever.
And look what it looked like.
Look at,
look how fucking fake it looks.
We'll get moves around.
Wow.
That looked like it hurt.
I said,
could we got fucked up?
Really done.
It barely even looks like it's there.
Like play that look a barely even looks
like it's there.
Like there's a guy in front of it and
he's looking at it.
What are you doing?
Singing?
I can barely see them.
It was look at that.
Okay.
It's weird.
And look at the fucking special effects.
Like what?
What was King Kong was like 1936 or
search shit.
33 wow.
So back then this was the greatest
fucking thing.
No,
you can't believe they even pulled this
off.
I mean this special effects for back
then were unbelievably incredible.
Like people were so excited to see this.
Okay.
When you look at like King Kong itself,
like show King Kong itself,
like when you see him working.
Cool guys getting up there trying to
figure out what happened.
Look,
look how fake this looks.
But this is a real lizard though.
I think they just stuck a real lizard in
there.
Nope.
Nope,
nope.
That's animated too.
Wow.
Sometimes they would do that though.
They would have a movie and they would
have like a real lizard and you could
tell the lizard was nowhere near them in
real life.
But they'd be like,
oh look.
And they would just insert this giant
fucking lizard in the back.
How weird was it had been to act in
these movies?
Okay,
there's a spider.
It's 16 feet tall.
It's coming at you now run.
Look at him.
He's like scrambling and then they have
to add in this killer spider.
This is nuts.
Look how bad it looks when they pick up
someone and they're getting bit
so stupid.
But that was as good as the world had
ever seen back then.
Yeah,
it was.
It was impossible to get any better.
Like that was incredible.
Like people must have been so excited
and there was no,
I mean what fucking TV shows Ron?
In 1936 how'd he do?
Two or 33 did they even have TV in 33
one did they invent TV once?
The event of TV.
Invention of TV,
yeah.
For a while it was just,
just movies.
Right.
TV would probably came a long time.
I was fucking radio like that.
I thought the Green Hornet was a radio
show and all that Shit TV.
I didn't find anything for WIC,
which
the invention of the TV.
Okay.
So apparently there's not,
not a single thing,
not single thing that you can point to
because there was a lot of shit that got
invented that related to the investment
around with a bunch of people and your
family and listen for the Green Hornet.
That'd be amazing.
Eight to nine every Friday night.
And then Wednesday was something else
and Thursday was comedy night.
Like they'd have like a lot Jackie
Gleason,
but the other guy like a little orphan
Annie,
it happened in 1862 was the first still
image that was transferred and this guy
had something called the Pan Telegraph.
So he transferred picture by telegraph
this thing or this electronic thing,
transfer it and they became the first
person to transmit a still image over
wires.
Fuck man.
They figured that out in 1862 you know
craze that is slavery became illegal in
1965 so while they were still slaves,
someone had figured out how to send a
photo over wire.
Fuck,
I've been wanting to,
telegram was huge.
Do you remember when you were a kid?
The Chally ran was huge.
That huge ground western union.
Western union was huge.
You got to go to western and then paid
cash and they've got their credit card
and that was the beginning of the end.
That shit.
That was the beginning.
This is incredible stuff,
man.
They uh,
in 19 and 18,
73 scientists may and Smith experiment
with selenium and light and this reveals
the possibility for inventors to
transform images into electronic
signals.
Fuck.
Did they figure that out?
I mean,
think about how nutty that is.
These dudes are riding horses and some
mother fucker figured out how to turn
images
into electronic signals so that you
could send her them sent,
send them so he can send them over.
Why?
Like I was fucking stupid.
I am a hundreds of years later.
What was the first picture of porn?
How to be or always dick probably guy
sets up chicken picture of his Dick is
poop poop find lady.
It was,
yeah,
some crafty cat.
It's like this bitch has got to see my
Dick.
If she sees my dig,
it's on right now.
She wants to stay in Philadelphia,
so fuck,
what do I do?
I'm in New Mexico sending pictures of
your slaves.
This is amazing stuff,
man.
So in 1900 they call it television.
It's the world Paris world's fair.
In Paris,
the first international congress of
electricity was held and that is where
Russian Konstantin pers ski.
Yeah.
Constant team Persky made the first
known use of the word television.
So it was invented by a Russian
gentleman or the word was at least
amazing.
You know when you go back and think
about dudes that were inventing like
really mind blowing shit like back in
the 18 hundreds or the fifth you know,
even earlier than that,
like the dude who figured out the
printing press.
Yeah,
but you know how much shit you didn't
have like fucking like interfering with
you.
Like you didn't have the Internet.
You don't have a TV,
you didn't have shit.
Oh,
he didn't get no credit.
The guy who invented math,
I bought that.
I give him credit every day.
That guy was off on fucking poor solar
trailer,
had no money for drugs and just started
putting shit together.
When I saw that on discovery,
I was blown the fuck away.
People who wasn't an invented math
methods.
Her one dude,
who knows?
I don't know.
But putting a battery,
the core of a battery,
a cold medicine,
just,
I,
you fucking kidding me.
Like what did you come up with?
Who gave you this recipe?
Was that numb?
Wasn't math used in World War II?
Like the story was that they used the
Hitler troops used it and the,
they used it on the Japanese kamikaze
pilots to get them to be willing to
speed.
I don't know if it's the shit that they
have now on a tub that know sons of
anarchy sells.
I don't fuck,
I'm just telling you that.
But what the fuck?
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
It's not a new drug.
And it was first made in 1887 again.
So 1887 yeah.
Uh hmm.
So I'm Germany of the picture of his
Dick to some chick.
So before he could invent the camera and
the gifted electronic wave,
you gotta stay up for a week to fucking
do it.
I'm sorry that that was just
amphetamines.
So in Fatto means for 1887
methamphetamine,
which was more potent and easy to make,
was developed in Japan in 1919,
the crystalline powder was soluble in
water,
making it for,
uh,
making it a perfect candidate for
injection.
Methamphetamine went into wide use
during World War Two when both sides
used it to keep troops awake,
holy fucking shit.
High doses were given a Japanese
kamikaze pilots before their suicide
missions and after the war mess and
methamphetamine abuse by injection
reached epidemic proportions when
supplies stored for military use became
available to the Japanese public man in
1950s,
methamphetamine was prescribed as a diet
aid and to fight depression easily
available.
It was used as a nonmedical stimulant by
college students,
truck drivers and athletes,
and the abuse of the drug spread.
Holy Shit.
Did you know that these to prescribe
methamphetamines for depression,
let's,
at least in the probably worked the back
door.
Yeah.
Well that was in the Liberace movie.
Remember the,
the California Diet?
He gave us a photo of them amphetamines.
You know what's crazy that I'm,
when I was growing up,
it was just crazy kid on the block to
me.
He had
whatever they diagnosed it,
Dennis add,
but they used to give him speed to calm
him down.
Right.
I'm going to be,
he was fucking used to jump off his own
roof.
Why would you do that?
Yeah.
Well they say that's a,
with a Ritalin.
It,
this was way before.
Really it was his sister used to sell
him as black beauties.
Oh really?
Yeah.
They had this kid on some heavy duty
Shit.
I used to go to East Stroudsburg,
Pennsylvania and buy a thousand black
beauties with 35 bucks and I would,
so what is exactly a black beauty?
It was just a little fucking black
things they made.
Then the 70s and they were the original
diet pill and it was an amphetamine and
then fed phenome.
Me.
What do you know what kind of was?
Yeah,
who gives a fuck?
There were $35 for it.
I sold him $400,035 for it.
I will sell them for 35 to 102 the
wrestlers,
a dollar a piece.
You have no idea what a cash cow,
that thing.
Oh my God.
And I remember like one night I went out
and I had no blown.
I ate like three of them drank and is
that,
and I was sick for a fucking week.
Like I never rate those pills,
but I remember people cracking them open
and snorting those motherfuckers.
You know what's really interesting,
you talking about that and you're
talking about selling bootlegging these
illegal drugs.
It's like,
it depends on how much money you make
and what you do with that money.
Whether or not you become legitimate.
I was a junior in high school,
but what I'm saying is like,
I know,
but look at the Kennedy's.
The Kennedy's did the exact same thing,
the same thing.
Kennedy's became legitimate.
It became a very wealthy and established
family for moonshine.
They were selling drugs.
They're selling liquid drugs that were
illegal,
but they did.
They did the right thing with all the
money they got out,
got ahold of it,
invested it in politics,
sending,
getting,
I mean they,
they did,
they had a lot of fucking money and then
you know,
they got out of it and once it became
legal or something,
I mean I know how the fuck they
transitioned at a bootleg yet,
but that's like the known history of Joe
Kennedy,
right?
The the father,
the father was like a,
he was a moonshine runner,
which is kind of crazy.
I mean how much different is that
really?
Then you sell on these black beauties.
It's really no different.
It's like morally or ethically it's the
same thing.
So like if you had stuck
with the black beauty business and then
got into politics later,
I mean that would have been,
that'd been acceptable.
I would say some of those were,
that was right after my mom died and I
was like crazy.
And I would go on Saturdays,
this kid nick be a Monte,
he was a football play up.
Then he would pick me up.
We drive like an hour and a half and
we'd go into this room and these college
kids that look like they were 40,
and that's all they did all week was
make different
things and they would make acid blotter
acid paper.
They would make four way acid.
They would make little Mescalin and
he'll make black beauties.
And that's what they did all weekend.
Their parents thought they were going to
school.
These are these,
you know,
before the computer nerd.
This is what nerds did.
They had,
this was,
these kids are probably millionaires.
I remember them having z 20 eights were
big and busy.
22,
1980.
Both had Iraq's with uh,
the cut moon dish that came out like,
no,
these guys were making money guys.
Meanwhile,
I'm him and I'm going,
I dad sent us money.
We don't go to class.
We pay rent.
They had a gambling thing during the
week.
These kids were banging.
If they were crazy little fucking,
uh,
I don't even know what they were.
Irish,
can't remember the tee tops.
Yeah,
the t top and Ted Nugent.
And we'd go and they show us.
These guys had a garage with jars of
black beauties jars.
That was that mainstay.
And then everything else they made as
they went along like this week won't
make blotter acid this week.
We'll make four away as it this week.
We'll make a window pane acid,
Trump fucking dick complete different
worlds.
Do you remember when everybody had that
trans-am just like Burt Reynolds with
the Eagle,
the hood.
It was a giant eagle sticker.
Like it was important to have that
sticker pull that bitch up.
Pull that a Burt Reynolds that was off
trans.
That Eagle stickers important man.
Like I know,
I knew a dude who had one um,
rebuilt headed a,
it was like for a TV show and they had
to get that sticker man.
That was like a big part of it was
putting that sticker on like you had it.
They had to get it like recreated.
So they get,
cause they restored the entire car.
Like that's how big of a fish out of the
one though.
It goes,
it goes back more cooler.
One has exposed headlights,
big feud with two people got an a high
rock in the same neighborhood.
My Dad became a few,
again to throw down,
I would park across the street and you
would probably across the street facing
the other direction and live a
headlight,
the loudest stereo on the hottest chicks
horn.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I be listening to,
I'll go fucking Nova and your fantasy
canyon.
Have you seen that video later when
you've got a minute at home to put the
video on?
Yeah,
that's it.
Beginning?
No,
that's not the one either because that
has clothes you gotta it's gotta be the
one with the exposed headlights.
These are all like new versions of,
that's the one that's the real one.
That's the Burt Reynolds.
Jimmy right there.
Oh Wow.
Look how bad ass that cloud was.
I think people who are not
male cannot understand that.
You know,
you show that to a woman,
especially like a mature woman,
but someone who's been at college,
they're going to look at that and go,
what the fuck are you?
What?
Go back to that picture.
It would be cool to,
it would be cool to have that like black
on like silver,
like where you could see only see it
like silver wise.
I was looking for a better one.
Well there's,
there's um,
people have done like little custom
ones.
I remember that.
I'd seen some,
some custom really cool spray painted
ones,
you know,
like,
um,
what's it called?
Air Gun when those are like Aragon
artists.
Remember that they used to do those.
Uh Oh that's a pretty dope one.
Remember they used to do like vans and
on the side of vans would be like some
fucking like a cone and scene.
I could do.
Yeah,
it was airbrushed.
Right?
There was a dude with the sword and you
know,
like fucking women like Frank Frazetta
style.
Do you remember that?
Like that was a big thing.
Those vans to have a bar in there.
You will Laurie.
Shit.
Why go to a hotel with the little
windows in the back of that roof dog?
We could smoke in here.
Popped a moonroof.
But that was like big time.
Yeah,
the blue roof was huge.
And what kind of artwork you had on the
side of your vans and fuck it.
You look at it and you go,
what the fuck was I thinking?
A fucking Japanese guy with a hammer
with efficient is sexy bitch.
I'm going to pull this up van with
airbrush artwork.
There's a couple of guys in Burbank that
have that.
They airbrush vans and it's like they
don't have,
they'll change them all the time and
then like the latest one was like wonder
woman.
It just,
she looked like a Mexican wonder woman.
Now
Dude,
go to that,
go to van with airbrush artwork,
it's still going strong.
There's still some fucking cool pictures
out there.
You just got to find these guys.
I still do it.
Definitely.
I didn't know.
I hadn't seen one in a long time.
I've seen cool shit on a like tour buses
and stuff.
This is the kind of shit that it's like
by me at my house like this is what it
looks like.
Awesome.
Come on man.
How awesome is that?
Luke Skywalker,
Obi wan Kenobi c three Po aliens.
That's pretty bad ass,
but there's a lot of them.
Yeah.
Okay.
Someone's got to have a frank Frazetta
out there.
I bet.
If I look up for Zena Airbrush Frazetta
that guy had in my opinion,
like the,
yeah,
well,
yeah.
Somebody who's got something here,
what does that,
that's how it looked like a Frazetta.
That guy had the best like fantasy art.
When you were a kid,
did you like for like Frank Frazetta,
did you,
do you remember those paintings,
you know,
is,
did you ever get into books or comic
books or any shit like that when you
were young?
I was big into,
I was into marvel like the four wa
marvel comics for a fantastic four.
I like the silver surfer and the only
reason it was a long fucking story I
see.
I was,
wasn't until 10 months we'd go to the
and the city and
we've tried to buy Batman three is some
shit.
He was just a couple months.
Then I went off the deep end.
It was,
no,
no more fucking comic books.
Now it's all spongebob 24 so fuck it.
Well turned around and came right back
to it for me.
I was a,
I was really into those,
um,
uh,
fantasy artists like Frazetta.
I'm trying to think of some of the other
names.
There's a bunch of other names of guys
who were like really a really famous for
that.
But for Zara was my favorite because it
was such a big fan of,
of the Conan series and he did a lot of
the,
um,
a lot of the artwork pull,
pull some of those pictures up.
Man,
they're credible.
He just,
it's just like,
that's to me,
like symbolized that kind of,
that genre.
A book.
Did you ever have a van Joey?
A Van?
No,
I drove a van for a construction,
you know,
a hardware company for about six weeks.
Oh yeah.
And then,
yeah,
I got fired though.
They're,
they're still fucking led the hardware
store on Fairview avenue.
Yeah.
When you go back and look at some shift
from your childhood,
it's trained.
When you see stuff that's still there,
the guy still fucking there.
That was the first I got arrested.
January 29,
1983 I got caught for possession of
stolen tools,
you know,
like a stolen property,
like the dude crying type shit,
like going out on bail.
I paid a fine,
I was on probation for six months or
something like that and that was it.
It was dumb as fuck.
But I worked at that lumber yard and I
had a good little job over there.
I was a delivery driver.
I could make my own little stops.
At that time I was doing a false,
like a,
a settlement type deal.
So I had to go to the chiropractor.
That gave me time to go to chiropractic
and all that shit.
Every day.
It was,
it was just a,
it was like two 50 a week and I work six
days a week.
Wow.
And I had to drive to the Meadowlands
and you know,
different constructions.
Tried to drop off tools and or no,
Liam and screws and nails as a shit you
do
your van.
Uh,
when I was about,
uh,
I guess I was about 18,
I had a van for awhile.
For a delivered newspapers.
I bought like a second car because it
newspapers would fuck up my suspension.
Like everybody who delivered newspapers,
your suspension got fucked up by the
Sunday paper because it's so much weight
cause you'd fill up your fucking trunk
with newspapers and then you put them in
the back seat.
You'd stuffed him in the front seat all
the way up to the ceiling.
So you were driving around like almost
completely blind at the right hand side.
Like it was very tricky like looking
around at where you were gone.
And so after a while I made it a little
bit of cash with this fucking venture.
And like me,
I'm always thinking of expanding.
I uh,
I got a van,
I bought this big ass cargo van with no
windows and then I expanded my route.
I was using him right wagons.
Well,
I had to figure out a way to make enough
money that I didn't have to do anything
else while I was competing.
And so the only way I could really think
of it before I made money teaching was
delivering newspapers.
There was the only thing that made sense
to me because it was several hours a
day,
like three or four hours a day,
but when it was done,
it was done and that's it.
There was no boss to answer to as long
as I delivered the papers to where they
were supposed to go.
There was no problems and I was good at
it.
I did it every day and it taught me
discipline,
like having something that you have to
do 365 days a year makes you fucking do
it.
You just do it,
you know,
we didn't even think of by step.
You just fucking do it.
It's part of your life.
You just get up and do it.
I applied for a paper route one time,
like going into the eighth grade,
I wanted to be a goody,
goody,
goody good.
And I applied for a paper out like in
July.
This motherfucker calls me like
Thanksgiving week and I don't even think
about it like,
okay.
And he goes,
you got to pick it up.
There was 43rd street hill.
This is a hill and a half.
There's one of those hills in my
hometown.
They can pay that San Francisco Hill.
Oh yeah.
Joe Rowe,
Lombard street walk over there.
It's fucking,
you know,
18 inches of snow that east coast snow
and I got to walk in for three weeks.
I had a breakthrough,
that fucking thing.
Go over there at four in the afternoon.
It's freezing.
The Sun comes down there.
You're fucking freezing.
I'm delivering pape and knocking on
people's doors with that,
that loop with the people's fucking
cards and nobody had one of those
things.
You gotta circle loop and you had
people's addresses when they paid your
last good tippers.
He had all that shit on it and I'm him.
After three weeks,
just quit and go on and down.
I ain't doing this shit no more.
That hell is a motherfucker.
I go work for my mother and make that in
one fucking day.
What I'm making for you,
40 bucks.
I got to hustle six days a week.
I go into my mother's for one day,
dad play with football or he fucking
Chinese food and come home and fucking
50,
60.
He got the fuck out of him.
I walk up and down the hill.
Fuck you.
Fuck.
I learned how to drive in the snow,
man.
That's what I learned.
I drive in the snow like all winter long
cause I drove every day.
I drove every day.
So if it smelled,
I fucking drove.
So I got so used to getting stuck.
I get stuck everywhere.
I'd slide in the trees like I fucked up
a lot of fucking,
my record was terrible.
By the time I moved to New York,
it was like really hard for me to get
insurance.
I had a gang accidents.
I was a horrible driver.
Then I made the mistake.
I'm moving to Aspen and you think,
oh,
what the fuck you're doing until there's
black ice on that motherfucker.
Oh,
and you're going down the road.
Listen to the fucking Joe Welch,
uh,
you know,
rocky mountain high.
You know what I'm saying?
Your car just like this red bag.
Just go shush and off that shish.
This back just starts fucking spinning.
You just go into a tailspin.
You don't know what the fuck to do.
This is going to fucking fucking
tailspin men.
I got to learn how to drive and pay
fucking attention.
This is a complete,
I hit so many fucking cars.
Joe Rogan dented so many cars.
I love.
I'm in Seattle.
I was a car salesman.
They used to give me a car.
I would take the car at night and go to
gigs to one nighters and I lose fucking
hubcaps.
Oh my God.
I was hard.
This is
a terrible,
terrible,
terrible video.
Not,
not this.
One of some people going down a road and
they lose control of their car and they
hit up a truck head on.
It's crazy.
The people from behind them are filming
it.
The guy in front loses his shit and just
at the right time swerves into the
oncoming lane.
Oh,
this guy just lost and oh my God,
here you go,
bitch.
Oh Jesus Christ is the scariest in the
wrong fucking lane.
Oh my God.
And he has to crossover.
How does it cross over?
I don't miss any of this shit,
man.
I grew up in Ohio,
so I had to deal with this all the time,
but look at this like you spun out.
Oh,
oncoming traffic.
Boom.
The only good part is when you got in an
accident,
it wasn't as bad because you were
sliding when you hit that.
It's true.
I mean,
that's a big deal.
That's a big deal.
When you got in an accident in the snow,
it's like bumper cars kind of.
Yeah.
People who don't know,
they don't,
they've never experienced that before.
Boom.
Like that in,
in any other situation would be a
devastating impact.
It still can be pretty shit.
This is bad because this is like,
oh,
this is horrible.
What is this guy doing?
He lost his shit.
Wow.
Like you give me anxiety.
I'm watching this.
I'm getting anxiety.
I really honestly think that people who
don't grow up driving in this kind of
Shit,
you,
you miss out on a certain amount of
adversity in life.
The fear that you get the respect for
the winter,
you know?
Oh my God,
Jesus Christ.
This is going to be bad guys spinning
out head oncoming traffic.
No one can stop.
How about the month?
Is that getting that call in Colorado
like that drunk?
Oh yeah.
Well don 82 82 route 80 to look it up.
It's one of the most dangerous roads in
the fuck it's going over the cliff.
Oh,
I spun around and got lucky.
This is scary.
Please shut this off.
This is not good.
It's not good for your spirit.
You're just seeing destruction.
That's the weird thing about like the
Internet and like choosing to go search
for shit.
Like you could see disturbing shit after
disturbing shit.
I was like,
you just be bombarded by nothing but
disturbing shit.
Whereas in a real life,
like it's really hard to run into that
much to start be shit,
but you could watch if you're,
if you,
if you drive every winter,
you might see one of those crazy pileups
in 10 years of driving,
we just saw 10 in a row.
You've lived with some places in Boston
with just disturbing waking up in the
morning.
It is and it's one disturbance and
everybody who comes to you after awhile
you start looking at them.
We're like,
what the fuck is this?
Like,
oh,
they put me on like that's how real some
places aren't,
man.
This place is situations you got
yourself.
It's just a walking disturbance.
Just the way you don't need to fucking
look at this shit or go online.
Well there's like a hopelessness to to
some places.
You know,
there's some places where when you're
like,
especially in the winter,
this is like a weird hopelessness.
There's no joy.
There's no aspect to it.
Like Aspen in the winter,
it's kind of festive.
People are scanning the town's Hoppen.
There's a lot of wood burning.
It's fucking amazing.
The woodburnings great wood burning your
whole heart stop.
Fuck beautiful.
It's beautiful.
I remember being eight minutes from the
greatest world,
the greatest city in the world,
and feeling hopeless like the Lincoln
tunnel going across from Lincoln was the
biggest city in the world in 1980 like
as a kid and going,
you know,
this is hopelessness.
This is too much.
It was too fucking much.
Then you know it was everything.
You wanted that at two in the morning,
everything you wanted.
You could buy a machine gun with a
bazooka in Harlem at two in the morning
you go up to Harlem,
there's a Puerto Rican that'll sit there
for 10 minutes and go,
let me think,
Bro,
what do you want?
What did the machine gun where the clip,
I want to shoot a thousand people.
I need to send like a fucking dynamite
and you sit there for 10 minutes.
If I get get it done in my tonight and
you're sitting there going,
oh shit.
Do you remember when that guy got
arrested in Harlem because he had a
tiger in his house,
Chimera,
that's,
that's Harlem.
If that story had happened in any other
place in the world,
if that was in Cleveland,
I'd be like,
how odd,
but it's in Harlem.
I was like,
okay.
I believe that the dude got bit and so
that's how he got in trouble is tiger
bid him and they found this motherfucker
had a tiger in his house.
He had like a bunch of exotic pets.
Let me pull up a story.
A man had tiger in his house in Harlem,
man.
Uh,
tiger is
Harlem is been gentrified.
Yes.
A lot of white people live in Harlem
now.
It's all the way up to 140 now.
Oh,
he didn't just need to clean,
you know,
he didn't just have a tiger.
He had an alligator to please.
Those are pimps in Harlem.
I mean as you call her,
this guy's house.
I used to cop coconut all hours there
that night.
I used to,
when I was 18 just out of high school,
I used to go to 135th Amsterdam where
you had a walk through the room with the
chickens are fighting,
right?
This is real.
And you walked through the room and the
chickens will fight and then you walked
into a Dj booth and they'd wait for you
and are times I go in and the cops were
there.
They wouldn't let you go on because
somebody got shot.
And then member,
when Mike Tyson fight in Harlem,
it form the fucking morning one night
called Mitch Blood Green.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I had a haberdashery.
Yeah,
the habit dash three at four in the
fucking morning.
What's a haberdashery and when you go
buy clothes,
men's clothing or something.
But brothers go to buy fucking clothes.
Who goes to what habit?
Dash rip one.
That's when you pulled from Tom when
you,
a gentleman called that Tom cruise ship.
But what was that movie man?
We had a call the Arabian guy and get
clothing and the chicks daughter was
fucking tremendous movie.
Tom Cruise.
Tom Cruise made a movie years ago with
Nicole Kidman as his wife and she had
cheated on him with a fucking soldier.
It was one of those weeds by director.
That fucking died shut.
Yeah.
Yes.
That was the thing.
All I remember about that movie is that
crazy dance.
Stanley Kubrick directed that so was a
demented movie.
They go to fuck the chicken.
The chick dies of a low d and the
doctor's office and he's telling the guy
to get it together,
but he has to wear a cape and a mask.
So he calls like this habit Dashia at
two in the morning in New York.
They opened up the fucking door and they
give him a cape.
And then the little Arabian girl fucking
the two Japanese employees.
This is a tremendous fucking movie that
he goes over there,
he gets in,
he goes to the back.
Everybody's naked every sucking and
fucking,
you've got to walk around with a Cape
and a fucking masculine magician's hat
on.
And then they threatened him and he goes
back home in the coke Kidman and she's
telling me that one night while he was
away,
she fucked a sailor.
So it's,
it's like going in his mind,
you know what I'm saying?
So it's just a fucked up movie he gets
to address from the piano player at the
jazz bar.
I took great movie,
by the way.
It's a dark fucking movie.
Remember they had it for a few years,
then they released it.
It was kind of weird because it was done
to working together.
I don't fucking know them
well,
eyes wide shut was uh,
it was about like some weird elite sort
of a cult Scientology through the back
door.
Yeah.
Was that what it was like?
It was like he was trying,
they release mask hung out with Callan,
stuff like that.
There's a 1972 there's some photos,
uh,
that,
Dunkin hat on his website,
um,
their photos from a 1972 Rothschild
surrealists dinner party.
It's so weird,
man.
It's so weird.
So this is the Rothschilds I guess I'm
not like totally up on this,
but they're supposed to be the people
that are like,
you know,
elite banker type characters,
right?
So they've got this,
uh,
this party and they're all wearing these
crazy outfits,
man.
Like this ladies wearing like a stag
head.
Like she has the head of a deer on and a
mask and the man is wearing this weird
thing on his fucking head and they have
this a dinner table set up with a baby
doll and like,
it's fucking trippy shit.
Really Weird Shit because these really
were the rock house and they,
this is really how they were rolling.
They really did have parties where women
would wear antlers on their heads where
they would have naked women,
uh,
pushed around on like a,
it looks like a casket covered in roses.
It's like,
it's really strange or at least an
effigy of a naked woman actually.
It looks like,
I can't tell if that's a real,
they kill a bitch.
They kill a bitch to they would kill a
bitch.
It's like just like a hipster party.
Well it's a bit of a party for sure.
Crazy People
party for sure.
But the,
I think the idea like some freaky shit,
if you want to follow the conspiracy
theory,
the idea is that these type of people,
these elite societies that what they
would do is they would have these
rituals and they would do something
really fucked up.
So no one could ever talk about it.
Like they would kill somebody.
Like they'd take a prostitute and killer
in front of everybody and then barrier
or somewhere
and no one to talk about it cause they
were all implicated then.
So that's everyone.
You know.
It's like your bond to this,
this cult that was the I,
I mean that's always,
look at that.
The woman's wearing a fucking staghead.
It's like a big deer mask.
How weird.
When you have like billions of dollars,
it's 1976 and you're like,
fuck it.
You know there was no internet.
You can't get in trouble.
There's no anonymous is going to fucking
take down your website,
can do some crazy Rothschilds character.
These people back then,
Jesus Christ,
to have so much money that you pay off
the attorney that night before the
party,
like a liaison for the police
department.
You're fucking have a service come in to
park cars,
the whole lot and there everybody has
mass.
So even if you do kill a bitch,
nobody knows who killed him.
It was some dude with a fucking goats
face on.
You don't know who the fuck that was.
There's no ids.
There's no nothing.
You're fucking bad back.
You're just spreading chlamydia like a
motherfucker.
Those things,
those I those,
no,
no.
I'm lying.
Those checks get checked out.
Those dudes go all,
they fucking send those bitches to the
doctor.
[inaudible] Pussy Scans,
ass call the whole fucking thing to the
best scan for pussies and the MRI.
I don't fucking know.
I don't,
you know,
it's gotta be something,
some fucking freaky shit.
Rock Springs,
Wyoming and shit.
I'm tired.
That's what he'd take those revitalize
them.
They put some peppiness well back in
those cowboy days,
right.
They used to have the brothels where
they would like go and this big fucking
wooden building in the upstairs.
I mean all the outlaw Josey Wales
movies.
I mean,
what was the movie?
Um,
uh,
the,
the comeback movie for him way back in,
you know,
like with Morgan Freeman,
unforgiveness.
Unforgiven thank you.
That movie was about prostituted a
broth,
getting cut up by a bad guy and then him
going after them.
Remember that?
Yes.
That's a good movie.
I was like,
great fucking movie.
Unforgiven as in my opinion,
one of the,
one of all time,
it's a black fucking sheep.
Nobody really wants exactly or Tosha
what types.
It's so realistic,
man.
It's like he went and did the exact
opposite of like,
you know,
like a a hero movie where everything's
predictable.
Like it was not predictable at all.
It was very dark and very realistic,
like very realistic and tuned in to
that,
that era,
like when he starts drinking and turns
evil,
like you fucking believe every word of
it when he comes in all sweaty and
fucked up and just kills everybody.
God Damn Dude.
And how everybody's freaking out.
They're scared.
They can't pull their gun out in time
and he's just blasted them one after the
other.
That was a fucking hard hitting movie.
We'll have to watch it again this week.
Maybe we'll watch a Milwaukee.
We have a party and some bitches,
that whole fucking thing.
I can't stand this age.
You can't stab.
They fight back.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't want to do it anyway,
but I would say that creepy shit when
they have quick parties,
the chick know she's going to die.
That's going to be hard when you do it
with like four people have families as
being sophisticated.
You're a millionaire,
you have so much to fucking lose.
But you know,
that's less than men when you have money
in the billions.
I can't imagine.
Listen,
you're 50 years old,
you're going to go fuck it.
I'm going to go do everything I've ever
wanted to do.
When you read a bucket list,
bitch,
and then that list is getting an eight
chicks chicks in the world,
getting them checked off a committee
here.
And uh,
I mean,
just,
you know,
Fidel used to do that.
They said that Fidel would go up to you
whether you are married or not,
he'd send the fucking guy over to you
and say,
call this number tomorrow,
two o'clock right in the restaurant.
You could be sitting there with your
wife or soldier would come up to your
wife and give her a card.
You've got to call that number the next
day,
next day.
Dot.
A fucking car comes to the house.
Picture your wife takes her for a
physical examination.
The next day she has to have a nice
dress delivered with some flowers.
She's going to Fidelis with some Yummy
ohms.
Wow.
So you would have to just address your
wife down.
We didn't,
you know,
you're just looking to make her look
like shit.
He was just steal.
Why?
I'm not sure about the wise,
but I know that he was doing it.
The women,
you know,
we was doing it to women.
Just you run a restaurant and you're
outside.
He would have people going out and
hunting bitches from that.
She got an enlisted guy.
That's a dictator.
Yeah.
Who knows what you do if you're putting
in that position,
you know I was watching that thing.
What's that crazy fuck from San
Francisco that made everybody to drink
the juice down in Guyana?
Oh Jim.
Give a watch that thing for two hours on
biography.
When you wake up and you can't go back
to bed,
you had like a fucking red bull at the
club and you're watching this and you
listen.
I can see you talking three people,
but he had thousands of people that give
them the social security checks.
That guy was raking and fucking,
he had them living in a hutch.
You imagine,
I'm going to give you my money.
I'm a living in a hunch with mosquito,
nowhere conditioner.
I got to do my own laundry.
What the fuck?
Thousands of people who are just lost.
You know,
we just wanted a new fucking life that
just,
that's mind boggling.
But about the branch Davidians,
I mean they had that place and then they
would leave the compound and go to jobs
and come back to the compound.
They all know they're making a comeback.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Something happened to Sun Fun should be
back there working under a new name or
something like that.
Then I need to call,
let's say come back.
Perhaps dividends come back.
Um,
I remember though when it was a wow,
they are trying to make a comeback,
but this was 2007.
Yeah.
Well they still gotta be trying,
you know,
that's a long come back.
I remember part of the,
the deal though,
the branch Davidians deal was that he
got the fuck them.
That was like part of his kid.
You know,
he's Jesus.
He's spreading the seed.
He's got to spread the love and you buy
it.
You got to sit there and look at your
wife and go,
God,
you know,
our lives will be better if he gives you
a fucking stabbing.
I mean,
it's disgusting.
I know somebody who lived through that.
Men,
one of those cults.
And I,
and she would tell me the stories and
they would sit there and ask,
why didn't she sued her parents and
today's world?
I would take her parents to fucking
court,
right?
Fuck will you people fucking thinking,
I mean,
they,
they tracked down,
uh,
they tracked down well,
what are,
you know,
they've trapped down in fucking people
from all of these wars that did walk
lines.
These are war crimes.
Listen to,
if a kid wants to do something,
he has to,
he has to be an adult.
He has to consent.
There's no kid that wants to grow up in
Indiana and some house with 80 fucking
kids where they,
they have to eat everything.
They chill and they,
even with drinking blood pudding and
shit.
So part of the deal was the guy fucks
your wife.
This family I'm talking about,
it hadn't made me nine kids.
Four of them belong to the cult leader.
So after the Colt dissolve,
now these people got to eat dinner in
the summers.
They're all on Facebook jumping up and
down.
This guy don't look like my fucking
brother.
You know what does that do to your
phone?
And the parents are sitting there
playing the guitar.
I was jumping up and down like you know
life is beautiful.
What the fuck?
Life is beautiful for your kids belongs
to some cult leader and your husband is
sitting there like a fucking savage.
I mean these are things that just
disgusting.
This is just disgusting shit.
They always get the fuck the women.
That's part of the deal.
That's part of the fucking deal and the
husband's got to sit there playing on
the guitar and making the Koolaid like
some fucking Jack off
like some fucking Jack off.
I mean I never understood this shit.
What's amazing when they studied cults,
how the same sort of pattern and that's
part of it.
That's part of the fall one cat at the
fuck everybody in this motherfucker.
It is part of it,
right.
Weird thing with men and they fuck like
17 year olds on the cusp of being 18 I
mean these guys were having that these
guys should be shot.
I heard that that particular guy was
still alive in a different state.
Who?
The defense?
The people I'm talking about the Dakota.
Either that they defunct from,
Oh,
this guy five and they're trying to show
him and,
Oh,
I thought you made crash.
Killed a few babies,
John.
Yeah.
They're disgusting after one.
How many minor league cults are there
out there that we don't know about that?
Is there a gang of them really?
Are the Mooney still around?
I read Christmas.
No,
the moonies.
The moonies where like an east coast
thing.
I don't even seem to have read Chris's
lately.
No.
No,
but the little head,
not in boulder then every other week,
but not,
no,
no.
I never seen him out here.
It's a nickname apparently.
I thought it was.
The real name is from the Unification
Church,
so on your moon and shit.
He was big in the 70s they can't
survive,
man.
It's the Amish.
Who the fuck?
No.
Let's see.
Recent use in 1996 article,
but the independent before foreign prime
minister Edward Heath gave at a
unification church sponsored conference.
He admitted the term Mooney has entered
the language and meaning at brainwashed
bright eyed Zombie 2000 foot.
Yeah,
I guess around still man.
Huh?
Yeah.
Wow.
Okay.
The unification church.
It's got to be harder to do on those
things today though.
No.
Wow.
I don't know if you have to get state
fucking approval.
There's some states that are like allow
colts.
Well you know,
as far as like religions cause the
church to church and get like a tax
deduction,
the whole fucking thing,
you know,
because um,
that's what uh,
that's what Alex Grey has that artist,
he's got a church,
like he's the one that does all this
crazy psychedelic paintings.
That guy's got a church.
I mean this,
uh,
his whole thing is a nonprofit,
like he's been approved by the
government.
Just pretty incredible.
We can all get approved.
Do you think so?
But who wants to neck fucking creepy
feeling?
I would never want that creepy feeling
to think that I was walking on fucking
water and then you throw all of them has
all become that.
They all become that.
I know have no way look back.
They all become that creepy person.
Yeah.
Is there anyone who's ever made a call
would worked out really good?
Well come up.
I don't.
I mean Holloway,
well Scientology works out good for some
people.
He does works out really good for Tom
Cruise.
Works out really good for John Travolta
or so really good for like the head
actor guys and like you know people who
are at the head of,
I mean whatever their,
their group of like top people in
Scientology works out good for them.
Is that a bliss cigarette that you're
smoking?
This is crack cocaine.
She's done.
The Bloomberg's trying to get rid of
those.
He should want to give a fuck.
I don't know.
Why do you say that?
Look at Jay Mccarthy.
She took over Stephen Door.
Yeah,
I know.
She's a new blue cigarette person.
I'll see that they went from black and
white to really color super hot check,
like black and white,
like film noir.
Well,
I guess doing that with this too.
The other one,
it's not.
You know,
it's so gross.
I like being silly with each other.
Ha Ha.
Let's make this,
ha ha.
He couldn't possibly smoking real life
and still be that hot kitchen.
Really?
You get tested this good googly Mowgli
and between fucking Hummus,
you got to do something with that
fucking mouth.
You know what I'm saying?
I had some nicotine with those jaws in
between.
Fucking,
she's beautiful gentleman really is a
hunger.
Jimmy.
She's still pissed at Jim Carry.
You can come visit the fucking kids.
I'm done fucking you.
I want to come see their kids for
right,
right or wrong,
right or wrong.
No,
she's pissed.
Listen,
we don't fuck no more.
I got to come see you kid.
When I was eating your rest.
I was his best friend.
I ain't eat your ass up.
I'm gonna come over and read them a
book.
Fuck.
You know it's the truth.
Yeah,
it is.
It's hard because a man man up now,
he's going to go have a family.
I got to go over to visit Jenny
McCarthy.
You know she wants to smoke that poll
and talking about,
he's been Dora.
You Know Jenny McCarthy.
I ain't mad at her.
I loved Jenny Mccarthy.
I been watching.
She's great.
She'd talk about how amazing you were in
ace Ventura.
Next thing you know,
she's swallowing your soil.
You're petting the cat.
He's fucking happy.
Get the fuck Outta here.
I can't be around you.
Fuck Jenny McCarthy.
Can you imagine being around?
You're single not,
I'm just trying to cut it out.
I'm going to fucking,
I'm gonna fucking ace Victoria to that
fucking door there.
Oh my God.
The competition for a woman that hot is
off the charts.
She's beautiful.
She's funny.
She's great.
She writes fucking books.
She's been around.
She's done a lot with playmate thing,
dog.
She's done a lot with it.
You got to really,
this chick was of Chicago.
White check came out as a comic with to
learn based on that show and I moved to
La.
That show was that.
It was getting cast by Judy Brown.
Stan hope was on it.
The fucking,
the,
the uh,
Jenny Mccarthy show I read for remote
control.
No,
control's it kind of MTV and MTV they
gave
was remote control.
That wasn't hurting.
That was a game show.
There was a different one.
Okay.
Singled.
That was with her and with Nerdist,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I remember that.
Yeah.
Come on now.
Jenny McCarthy is a bad bitch.
Stuck around a long time,
man.
No fucking dirty movies.
No nothing.
Nobody's got a picture.
I suck my cock.
Nobody.
Nobody's got a picture of Jenny McCarthy
did.
It wouldn't hurt her.
She would just,
oh no.
She looks beautiful.
She's fucking,
and I'd ask this.
They used to be a,
that would be a deal killer for a woman
back in the day it killed and almost
killed the check from Miss America.
What was the check check?
They called Pussy.
I picture.
Look at that picture.
Look at that picture of what a good,
in 1980 $4,
Korea and that bitch came out with
albums.
Bam.
Married a lake up band.
What's her name again?
Vanessa,
Vanessa Williams.
Williams.
She was beautiful.
Yeah,
man,
it's fine.
Look at the picture of her eating a
fucking monk.
Woah,
shoot.
She's on all fours.
He's got a fucking nostrils.
And that's a very beautiful woman.
That's a beautiful woman.
You know.
Now she's 50 she's 40 I mean,
you know,
I'm talking about when she was 20 she
won Miss America.
They took the crown from her cause
somebody fucking develop those pictures.
Yeah,
no floors.
It was a different world right now.
They would like encourage that.
Yeah.
Now you do that.
You gotta fucking showing the Kadesh
underneath.
Yeah.
And that way people would pay attention.
You know,
having something like that.
I mean,
look at Paris Hilton and Kim Kardashians
made them really,
I mean it made them more popular and
this chick had a ton of fucking,
I mean she put out a music every once in
a while.
I still put the out month running back
to you.
Tremendous dancing shit.
1991 92 she did movies too,
didn't she?
She did the movie with Arnold.
Oh Shit.
What was that?
What was that move witness.
She was a witness relocation plan and he
took her and she stole the this from the
company and come on now.
Yeah,
man.
She made us and then she was on some
other TV show for awhile.
That's a bad ass mother fucker.
Damn.
That was a long ass time.
Yeah,
she's been around for a long time,
but they killed it with that pussy.
A picture of her eating some pork girl
having a glow.
Yum.
Yum knowledge.
If she got to Texas,
I don't know.
Look and see if she's not aware she's on
it.
She's not a somewhere.
You see what they made her life and
she's tall too.
Is She?
Yeah,
she's tall.
Vanessa Williams.
There's another one in an actress there
was named Vanessa Williams too,
right?
Remember that?
I don't know.
Remember there was two Vanessa Williams
for awhile and it's fucking confusing as
shit.
There's Vanessa l Williams and then
Vanessa Williams.
Yeah.
Oh,
okay.
Where's she from?
Um,
she is from mill New York.
What'd she go to?
College,
Texas.
I don't know.
Something happened.
It's actually,
Sensei doesn't say,
but yeah,
she's um,
Nah,
I can't share that one.
She's born in.
She's born in [inaudible] 63 so she's
50,
50.
I don't have a guy now.
I see what you just got a couple kids.
Still works a lot of ABC shows.
She's still beautiful times a mother
fucker,
dude.
It waits for nobody.
MMM.
And waits for no.
Oh,
there's another Vanessa Williams.
Okay.
There's a young girl.
No,
you go right there and look at it
because he's,
the next is rock.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
It's just like a pumpkin.
Is there
fresh look how big it is.
Pumpkin.
Yeah,
I'll wear,
yeah,
we can't show that you get in trouble
folks.
We can get trouble.
Um,
yeah,
it's,
it's weird when you go back and look at
like,
do you ever watch a movie from that era?
Like,
um,
uh,
I watched,
um,
what was that movie where the guy played
the video game and the video game taught
Starfighter remember that was the guy's
name is Alex Rogan.
I remember that.
Cause uh,
yeah,
but she's got my last name and he was a,
a,
a guy who learned how to a pilot.
Is this,
uh,
this spacecraft during playing this
video game?
The best at it?
No,
no,
no.
It's like star Star,
Star fighter.
Last star fighter.
Was that it?
Yeah,
it was so stupid.
Was it?
What's his name?
The black dude.
And he was like a dress.
He looked all weird and creepy.
The black guy.
Which buck?
Uh,
the one,
it says the stars.
Lance guest,
Robert Pete Preston,
k,
e,
cuter.
See full casting crew.
I fit in,
I know.
Latch.
Just look up the last star fighter.
I was thinking of something else and
they're like,
hey,
this,
this video game guy seemingly doomed to
stay in his true a park home all his
life finds himself recruited as a gunner
for an alien defense force.
Who was,
um,
remember this guy's name?
He was the main guy in it.
Right?
But yeah,
that was the main guy in it.
Who was he?
I forget.
I thought he was somebody.
I think you thinking of a enemy.
Mine.
That's what hopeful.
And you're thinking of a Louis Gossett,
is that what it is?
Louis Gossett jr the guys
got 100% right.
He's the man from,
remember that officer and a gentleman
that was a great fucking movie.
That was great.
Took me months to watch that.
I couldn't get over them cause I had a
girlfriend that liked that motherfucker,
so I hate it.
I hate it.
That motherfucker.
I went to see American Gigolo and he
showed his ass.
I lost my edge after that.
And then he'd come out with office and
the gentleman,
my quarter for 78th street for $5 with
default hearts.
Why even buy one and the other chick,
that was the first big movie they gave
Steven Bauer after Scarface and fucking
officer.
The gentleman,
what the fuck your bed at an orgy.
Listen to the rolling stones.
Bad mouth in your country.
He's dropping some knowledge that Lou
Gossett started busting on oak school.
Karate moves is Chodo con karate moves
and he was like,
tell her,
oh my God,
you CSI Miami was in there.
That dude that was taken out.
I remember he pulled them up and choked
him out.
He tapped out and then they threw him
out of that.
Plus the other guy was in that movie
officer and a gentleman is deep pull up
the fight scene from officer and a
gentleman.
There's a couple of them,
but when he walks up on them,
anybody want to come up here?
How about you Megan?
Nays that's right.
I remember his name was Mayo,
but let me tell you what the baddest
part of that movie is when you really
realize who fucking Richard Gere's is.
The first scene when his father comes in
and they just had an orgy,
his father was played by Frank Lopez
from Scarface,
fresh off Scarface and fucking whatever
his name is.
Just combing his hair.
I don't want some,
his father comes any moves over.
He takes his dick out and he's pissing
in front of him.
He goes,
that was some fucking night.
not like those bitches and Thailand.
I mean,
he was just,
he goes,
where are you going?
And he goes,
I got to drop some money.
I'm a fucking officer.
And he goes,
look at you,
you ain't no fucking office.
And he hits the glass.
You Shit,
you ain't no fucking officer.
Look at you.
He goes,
what's your problem?
You might have to salute me someday.
Fucking tremendous scene.
He walks out.
Where you going?
Come on.
I was the only kid.
That's a great fucking movie or a movie.
That scene in the beginning.
That was Frank Lopez.
Those are,
those were,
that was Frank Lopez.
I think it was after Scarface.
So he left Scarface getting shot.
You know they threw him out of,
there you go.
That's when he's trying to,
he's telling me quit.
I've changed.
I've changed since I've been here.
I've tried.
Sorry.
Just polished up.
You're asking them,
shined it up.
Tell me what I want to hear.
I want your DOR.
I watched y'all real quick.
Spell it.
D.
O Oh,
they got to quit.
Yeah.
Then you can be free and you and your
daddy can get luck and go home.
I ain't going to quit right then.
You can forget it.
You're out.
That's the line right here.
Oh God.
Nowhere else.
I got to go.
I got it.
Are you fucking kidding me?
It was incredible.
I forgive him for all his crazy
Buddhists bullshit.
Remember after nine 11,
we need to use love.
He got on stage in New York.
I was like,
we need to use love and love them.
Like,
Ooh,
I dunno if that's the right answer.
We need to figure out how to stop planes
from flying in the buildings for worry
about love.
People aren't going to be not flying
planes into buildings because you were
really good and officer and a gentleman,
he uh,
he,
I remember he was,
he was on the belt buckles to fucking
those dudes.
He was due for CSI.
Miami comes up in this dog.
Is it worth you making a couple dollars?
Oh,
that's right.
That's right.
It was selling [inaudible] belt buckles.
Sorry,
got the trophy dog trouble cause he was
hustling.
God,
what's his name at the store?
One that I shook his hand.
He's like a big Aa guy,
you know Lou Gossett Jr is he?
He was at the store one night,
man.
Cool it.
Fuck,
I shook his fucking hand and I said,
Doug Office and the gentleman,
you know,
you were bad.
Dude you've been,
you got a tremendous resume.
Do you remember good times?
Fuck yeah.
I saw the father up.
Got To remember we all the time.
I used to be a standup comic up here.
Oh he was.
He was fucking hilarious,
man.
Johnny Moss.
He was,
that guy was fun.
He was so nice,
dude.
Yeah,
very,
very fucking nice.
He was the first like really famous
guide that I ever met that I didn't feel
weird talking to him.
He gave you no judgment like he was just
hanging out with you.
He was a fan of comedy.
He respected it.
So that's the difference when somebody
sits back then goes dog,
I appreciate what the fuck you do.
I tried it for three years and it wasn't
me.
I remember the dude from bad ass act.
Johnny Palumbo
always come into this store.
Glenn Plummer,
who's at black dude that was in the
movie with Sean Penn when they did it
more with the gangs in La,
and then he did a thousand things.
I just saw him and fucking son's I
Anika.
I mean,
he's still working.
I stole him at the store.
He didn't come up to me and go,
dog,
what you do?
And I'm like,
really?
You don't want to do it?
I remember hosting at the store,
bringing them up,
but I'm going to dog.
Please don't embarrass me.
I go,
you've done movies with fucking Andy
Guards.
Shaya he sent two things to do in
Denver.
When you're dead.
See the two black dudes.
It's him and the dude from fucking this
guy called,
yeah.
He used to come to a store all the time.
That guys excellent.
Yeah.
He just got shot on sons of anarchy and
last two seasons or something like that.
It's amazing of John Amos was the first
guy that,
uh,
that ever gave me a compliment to that
that was like famous.
Like the first guy that I ever talked
to,
like the told me that a good time am I
am at a show.
They were sitting the back of the store
all the time.
A great time.
And it would come up to you and talk to
you about that man.
Joey,
I'd love when you did this big man.
The way he did that.
And I remember I used to have that tiger
fucking bit.
Yeah,
yeah.
Chemo to me one night after show it,
he goes,
you're so free up there man.
He goes,
it's you're so free.
And I even,
I
had to figure out how to do that bit
right.
And one of the ways that I learned how
to do that bit right,
it was like,
you know,
do it different ways.
And he kind of explained to me like what
was good about it?
He,
he like,
cause he's such a great actor.
Like even in good times,
like he's watched that show.
Yes.
Fuck yeah.
He says that's right.
He got his foot chopped off.
Remember?
Yes,
he was rude.
He,
he was so good as an actor.
Like even in like a sitcom.
It's like he had these powerful fucking
moments,
right.
So when he told me,
it's like,
you know,
like yourself,
it's so we free up there when you're
doing that,
you so free because you're not thinking
about shit.
He's like,
you,
you like thinking like that tiger.
And I realized like,
that's really the way to do it.
You've got to actually almost pretend
you're a tiger.
Like think like that thing thinks.
And that's the way it works.
I kind of figured it out because of him,
because of him talking to me about it.
I was like,
Oh yeah,
that's it.
That's it.
And it was,
it made me so confident because he
built,
because he said that,
you know,
like Jesus,
John Amos said that it's gotta be right.
It's like this is 100%.
Like that's the guy from roots.
That's the guy from good times.
That's John Stamos captain room or
coming to America.
That's right.
We're compatible off the drugs.
Uh,
that's incredible.
I watched old mythologically again the
other night.
Oh,
the Richard Pryor documentary to watch
it.
Yeah.
Dude,
that makes me nervous.
You got to watch where he goes to the
Hollywood bowl when he goes to the
Hollywood bowl and goes off.
It's amazing for some gay foundation,
the people.
But you know,
what did he do?
He went to the Hollywood bowl for this
back thing or style in the middle of the
support gay people and he got up out
there.
He goes,
what the fuck were you when they burned
him?
Watch,
you could kiss my rich black ass.
Fuck.
And they got off in the host got hurt.
I'm so embarrassed.
Oh my God.
And they're booing him.
And the next day it was in variety and
shit.
Really?
You know,
they gave him more of his dog and they
took it back.
He made Jim Brown,
the president of his company.
How much blower you doing?
Well,
he was doing a lot of things with Jim
Brown.
Jim Brown was in his act.
Remember Jim telling them to get off
cocaine?
Very interesting.
Oh,
Midville Hillary.
Yet.
You know what men,
it makes you scared because you know
that there's parts at the relate.
We're obsession at other ways.
You know what they are.
We're obsessed in other ways that
whatever,
that doesn't have to be cocaine.
And when he was married seven times
drove,
well what about the time when he went
upstairs to the bedroom?
They got to go to the next morning,
knocked on my door.
I go,
Richard,
what are you doing?
He goes,
I got to get a divorce.
You know?
It was just crazy.
That's crazy shit.
But that's what people don't know is
when you're in that zone and you to the
comedy store,
the Chinese guys are giving you the
drinks in the back.
I can't even imagine.
I couldn't be,
I couldn't imagine being mentally
Kennison was there with Lemmy clock and
there's 18 head is in the back and
everybody's drinking Mitzi shore and
know we always talk about this,
but we got to show the mental side of
the comedy,
Bro.
You gotta be a savage.
There's a part of you that after a
certain level you have to become a
savage.
You really do,
man.
I'm a savage and I'm proud of it.
Yeah.
There's no way around it.
If you don't do it,
you won't survive.
Like the very thing that you need to
become a a real comic.
It's like you have to have this freedom.
You have to have a freedom of thinking.
You have to of ability to go to these
dark places.
And we did.
We learned that from that fucking crazy
haunted house.
You did a little,
but you learned it there.
You learn it to learn how to be changed.
Listen man,
I remember being 16 and going home.
You had junior in high school.
I wasn't sleeping.
I mean at this time there was no sleep
apnea.
I just wasn't sleeping well.
You were doing coke,
doing coke by myself,
by yourself.
Go home and listen to master reality by
black Sabbath into the void and people
hope to hang on the road.
And I would put due to coke and I
probably do a little hit of masculine
too or something to get me going.
And I'd sit in that fucking corn.
I didn't smoke cigarettes,
I didn't do nothing.
I just go do this.
Look,
I'd rock like a fucking retard back and
forth.
I still remember that shit and I'd be
like,
Jesus Christ,
this is my life.
I'm going to fucking kill somebody else
up to this shit
days can you stay up for before you
start going crazy?
There's a number,
right?
Three.
How many days have you ever done it?
Coke.
How many days you stayed up?
I have never done that.
Never stayed up.
I never did that.
I said I went to bed.
How many days have you stayed at one
time?
I stayed up three nights,
Saturday and by Saturday night I kept
calling the police.
Right.
I could call the police.
Tell me about that.
For somebody in my house.
Right.
And they kept,
there's one that was house sitting on
far away road and Snowmass village.
Wow.
Okay.
And I'm up there like me and my
girlfriend,
we're going to have huff listen to this.
Me and my girlfriend at the time,
I'm going to her brother's wedding and
I'm going to meet her parents for the
first time and I went to New York and I
got two answers have blown like gay.
Went to the electrician buddy of mine,
and I started holding them to this.
I'm going to pick it up the night before
I go to fucking this wedding and I get
there by 11 o'clock on a Thursday night,
I pick up the ounce.
I go home about one o'clock the
motherfuckers calling me,
I do a line,
I do another one.
Let me tell you how bad it got.
The dog I had at the time,
Hercules was probably a year old.
I loved him.
I didn't let them out of the House the
whole weekend.
He held that pistol like a soldier.
You know what sent me?
I didn't let her whole weekend the hell
was going to hit.
I wouldn't let him out.
This is not crazy.
I possible.
Who the fuck cares?
You didn't piss.
I kept looking at him every time he
cried.
That's it.
You ain't going out.
And I had no porn.
Right.
So I whacked off to,
what's the movie with the Lady in red?
Vanessa Redgrave.
The lady in red.
The chicken there was married to Steve
Seagal.
You're fuck.
Oh.
What is her name?
Michelle Brock.
Look.
Kelly.
Kelly,
Lebron and woman and red shows up pussy
for a slip.
Second us.
Yes she does.
When gene wilder cause for her.
When gene wilder cause for her,
she runs off to bed and they show her
Bush.
I figured out what the VCR,
how to lock it on the fucking Bush,
and I'd sit there with my Dick and my
belly button and I'd walk it off and
then I'd hear him.
Something happened and I called the cops
and that's when the third time they sat
me down.
They're like,
listen,
you got to stop doing cocaine.
I had the cocaine hidden in the sink,
so if somebody happened,
I lift a water and hit the compressive
button over here.
But there's one tiny minute and in lady
in red where she shows her fucking
pussy,
she shows her bread hot panties.
Right?
That's the idea.
No,
she gets up off the bed.
It says let's her dress fly and chose
her red hot pants.
Now which one gene wilder come calling
for and she gets up and it shows that
little Bush all that drove me fucking
crazy.
I sat that she,
she reminded me of an old girlfriend in
high school.
She was beautiful.
God,
gene wilder.
Gene Wilder and her were in a movie
together.
Naked.
That's what I'm saying.
We can approximate breeze.
Yes.
I know.
I know him.
Three San Bernardino.
That's crazy.
Lady in red.
That's what it was called.
Lady.
A woman in red.
I'm sorry.
A woman.
She was in Steven Seagal movies too,
right?
She was in,
she was ended up back from war,
whatever,
like back from the war.
She started and he started to beat that
member.
I don't know.
Yeah.
He started beating her and put
membership is an acupuncture.
True.
Yeah.
He was her acupuncturist and when they
just started a beat,
they said,
fuck the needle
making shit up,
man.
No,
he did beat it.
He did something so she's pissed.
She was on celebrity Rehab,
one of those celebrity losing weight
show.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I'm telling you guys what,
come on now here.
Yeah.
She's,
I think Steve's to Gal stowed movie was
with her back in danger.
Whatever the fuck with the kid.
They shot the kid and him at the wife
and then he went to the ranch.
Yeah.
She know.
She gained the weight.
Steven Seagal stress,
man.
A lot of God damn stress.
She moved to a fucking ranch and started
eating potato chips.
There was no stress with that.
Steve was a guy money.
She saw what he made on one of those
fucking movies.
He was a guy was getting paid though for
awhile.
He was a big mega star.
No doubt.
Look at.
Yeah.
When he was doing like above the law and
all those movies and blah,
blah,
blah.
The good movie.
Don't ever get confused moving.
They wouldn't never gave him the other
eight if above the law in the beginning
when he's doing the class with the Guy
Kido dude.
Oh yeah.
That's how the movie starts going down a
good chunk.
Gotcha.
When he goes to that bar,
starts slapping people with that fucking
straight arm to the neck.
That was true.
Then he started killing Jamaicans.
What was the mood with the fucking
Jamaicans and shit?
I see that black dude auditions.
Just Shit.
I want to shake his head.
What's the mood with the Jamaicans when
he went to the mall?
What's the Colombians in the Santa
Maria?
Fucking tremendous.
That movie that was was that movie that
was back for more.
Oh,
that's funny.
Okay.
What is is a Wikipedia and find out what
the fuck that movie is.
He's still banging out.
Mover marked for death.
That's a good one.
How many movies you think he's done and
take us?
60 to 67 I bet he's done.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Uh Oh.
He did stunts in some earlier movies,
man.
Never say never again is a James Bond
movie was a martial arts instructor in
that view to a kill.
And then above the law was like 88.
Yeah.
That was his first movie.
Damn.
This motherfucker's dot whole.
I kidnap that dude and the cops were
looking for me.
I hit that with above the law and lethal
weapon and I fucking watch them over and
over and I was blown away by above the
law.
I really was.
I was blown up the Jamaicans,
what was his name?
What was it?
Quiz.
What was the fucking black one eye.
Glass side.
What was the Jamaicans name?
He killed the brother.
And then the brother popped up when you
know he had a glass side.
Right.
Something,
something real.
His fight scenes in these early movies
were like the first realistic fight
scenes in a movie.
We're dude was like slapping guys arms
down and fucking knuckle on them in the
face.
It wasn't like these giant.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
It was like more like that.
It wasn't like it was first time we were
sorry Quito,
but it was also,
it wasn't like like a giant flying split
kick.
We kicks two dudes at the same time.
Yeah,
it was.
It was more brutal than we'd ever seen
in movies before.
Like as far as like karate scenes,
it seemed more brutal and more
realistic.
Never saw Steve was a guy moving to
black movie theater,
but it wasn't that they go fight and
they cheer for white people.
Black people don't cheer for black
people or white people smacking the
fuck.
I saw two,
I saw the second rambling on the 78th
street in Harlem.
It was one of the funniest things I had
ever won till this day.
I always said when he fucking comes and
when he opens his eyes and the mud.
I remember that scene when he opens his
eyes.
Yes,
the German guy,
black people went fucking bananas dog.
But then I had never seen nothing like
that.
I can't even imagine a Steven Seagal
movie other than 78th street back in the
day.
We missed the window.
The window was in like right,
right about above the law.
If you got in and above the law in the
1980s and went to Harlem and watch
bubble,
ah,
I bet it would be one of the most
incredible experiences of your life.
Who Laugh your ass off.
I saw planting the fucking apes and
Philly and me and Tommy Jr and his girl.
We went to a a theater in the middle of
filming and this was like a,
when the UFC had the fights in Philly
and we got there like a day early.
We played pool and we got,
we got so high,
we were terrified of her own shadow and
then we went to this black neighborhood.
It was the only way place that they had
that we didn't even know.
We didn't know it was like an urban
neighborhood until we got there.
But once we were in the theater,
we were like,
oh my God,
we're the only way people here.
There's like maybe like three other
white people.
We found each other,
we huddled together and then once the
movie theater,
but when we got in there,
it was hilarious,
man.
There's dudes who are artists at Yellen
shutout this dude.
This dude's are artists.
It,
oh,
you fucked up now.
Oh,
like I don't like it for the most part.
Like it's gotten bad at it.
It's gotta be funny.
If it's funny.
It's brilliant.
Yeah.
And some dudes try too hard.
The worst is when there's a funny dude
and is not funny.
Friend is like fucking really loud.
He tries too hard.
Like one dude say some funny shit and
then his other friends will chime in and
try to like top him and they can't.
They don't know.
They're not funny yet.
I saw Clint Eastwood Marathon in San
Francisco in the tenderloin when Clint
Eastwood tells the guy to pick up the
gun and the black guy yelled from the
back shoots that black motherfucker,
the place went down.
He just shoot that black
when the,
when a plant of the apes,
it's amazing.
Did you see planet of the apes new one?
He didn't say it this fucking good Joey.
It's fucking good.
I enjoyed it.
I know you wouldn't go see the mechanic.
You wouldn't go see that was adjacent
stadium was Jason's see them once a
mechanic.
You wouldn't go see that out of respect
for Charles brought up whether it was on
television.
I caught the first time.
Minutes.
I mean that it's show time and I was
correct.
You're correct.
They blew it.
Well it wasn't as good.
But let me tell you something.
That dude who played the bad guy and due
to plate as apprentice,
that mother fucker's wicked.
He was in that stupid vampire movie 30
days of night.
Did you ever see that movie?
No.
Good fucking movie.
He aint no jam.
Michael Vincent,
1970 right.
Dram,
Michael Tropics and Jan and Michael and
[inaudible] 73 he was,
he was taking his dick out on Wilshire
Boulevard and they will line up to
sunset the suck that blood.
Especially after the movie.
He did not baby blue marine come on down
and they put them with the ugliest man
in Hollywood,
Charles Bronson and he went crazy.
Right.
He goes crazy.
It looks like a fucking truck at him and
went nutty.
Yeah.
Poor guy.
He was a Malibu weed pills,
drinking cocktails.
Told people is a pilot.
They say that that's the place to go if
you want to eat pills,
if you want to be like a rich old
person,
each pills mal beaus your spot like
everyone in Malibu.
It was like,
you know there's like a,
a bunch of refugees from Hollywood that
are older and just chewing pills now.
Like littered in between people who like
to jog and ride bikes.
There's like just people staring at the
ocean,
just popping pills,
all that.
I don't the worst thing a month,
those pills but how long they stay in
your system and you know you don't feel
it while you're reading those things.
Not till you get off those things.
Like when you get a prescript you get a
knee surgery.
I feel bad because America doesn't
really know.
You didn't eat your viking.
It was after your surgeries.
No,
I don't like that stuff.
You'd rather take it out.
I leave because you'll know.
You'll know what it does for you.
It destroys your system at each a pot,
your fucking stomach lining.
You got to eat tons of fucking yoga with
them pills or a slow fucking death in
this country and people have no idea.
Didn't front,
but I was never really an opiate guide.
Some vines I spotted some coke.
Forget the deck going gorilla biscuits,
but there's people.
He goes,
I like that thing.
You always talk about that Florida road
documentary about Florida,
the oxycontins fucking idea.
I told you dog,
I did a 16th when the time my blood
pressure went up,
I had to lay down.
Those things are different.
That synthetic heroin ain't the best
thing in the world for you.
You might as well pull off the street
and do a little bump.
Synthetic heroin is made not to fucking
addict you,
but the fucking destroy.
You know?
It's like cocaine.
It's like now I go to places I listen.
I really enjoy getting high uh,
red band.
I really do.
But guess what?
When you show up with a fucking DAB and
a pipe and a fucking torture and shit
like that,
it's time for you to stop.
Why does everybody always want to make
crack out of everyone?
I know.
First they did it to coke.
You just couldn't snort coke no more.
Now I've got to mix it with gasoline and
fucking toenails.
Pulling a draw with paint and,
and smoke it.
No,
no,
no.
That's not strong enough.
But that's what people are always doing.
It's just amazing.
Now.
Only wants to stick into your ass.
Now you got a good point there.
At least a finger,
but now you know,
they got so much fucking weed stuff
coming at you and it's great.
But I still like rolling the fucking joy
like I'm done.
I still like all the,
you know what I like about Ron giant
man.
I like the,
the,
the like the Karma,
the energy.
It's Virginia.
It's like the paper.
I wanted to say this celebration of it,
but it's not the celebration,
the ritual.
That's what I wanted.
I was looking for.
I like the ritual of like here we got
like I'm preparing for it,
I'm getting it rolled up.
Smoked some right now in Florida.
Um,
this is the craziest statistic ever.
We've read it before but if you haven't
heard that podcast,
Florida prescribes 10 times more
oxycodone pills.
Then every other state in the country
combined
fucking eat.
Damn Z.
That's a scary,
scary thing that that those pills,
it's like taking over so strong at,
I had the blow concept to this now.
Dot.
Florida.
It's like so many oxy cottons everywhere
now you're adding blown away.
Would it be cool if they had an APP to
show where people are sober?
If like your,
your APP.
Like if you hold your phone it tells you
if you're on heroin and just they,
you'll look,
I got a map like we were looking at that
porn map,
all the cream pies and all that chin.
Find out how,
what percentage of Florida is not on
pain pills right now.
Ready Go.
We are not hip enough,
but I guarantee that with three years
behind that there is somebody right now
moving kilos of cocaine online through
ups or whatever,
one of those systems and nobody even
knows and a delivery system.
Well,
you know about Silk Road if you're heard
about solar on about nothing,
but I'm just saying that there's gotta
be somebody who's selling coke on
Twitter.
Well,
there was an article about it.
Um,
there's an article about a website that
somehow or another is able to transact
elicit deals and people sin poop
senders.
If you want to buy any pip,
they got gorilla poop.
Turgor cow poop.
Elephant crap.
Gorilla pit.
Why would anybody want to buy a poop was
look up.
See if there's a,
what does that Silk Road thing that's,
that's the thing that everybody you're
talking to.
Can't look it up.
Don't talk about it or whatever.
It's too late.
If people know about it,
the government knows about it.
It's all over the news bed bath and
beyond.com.
Yeah,
just something like that.
But they're,
um,
there's ways that people are doing it
where they're,
they're figuring out how to put,
I mean,
how long are they gonna be able to do
that?
And then what happens if somehow in the
future,
you know,
they can go back retroactively and like
look up the database.
So who bought heroin or whatever through
this fucking crazy website?
Of course.
No,
you wouldn't believe me.
Anybody who's going to buy heroin
online,
there's going to be a little crafty.
If you got to hide your name,
it's going to be a comment or on
youtube,
you're not going to go on there as Joey
Diaz and say crazy shit about Taylor
swift.
If you've got a,
if you have a,
if you have a match and you know,
you have,
uh,
you know,
I think you,
you controlling your heroin use,
you could quick a fucking switch and 20
minutes later some guy delivers it to
your door that,
you know,
you know them.
But this is the new way.
You don't even have to pay a no more.
It seems like once there's a desire for
something,
it's impossible to stop people from
figuring out a way to get it to people,
especially if it's illegal and it only
makes sense that they'd be using the
Internet.
Right.
It's brilliant.
It is brilliant.
There's no way else.
I mean,
it's going to happen,
right?
I mean,
it's not like anybody's going to hide
that shit.
Speak speaking to Haydn.
That shit.
Listen to this.
There was a dude in China that got
arrested.
He,
uh,
he went to jail and because he convinced
a girl that she,
her vagina was haunted and that he had
to get rid of the ghost with his penis.
So they arrested him for this.
They arrested him after he claimed that
he get rid of it.
The paranormal enthusiasts allegedly
charge 3000,
$250 to perform the sex or CISM.
What a brilliant man.
Come on,
man.
That dude is a pimp and you're hating
your hating on that guy.
Fuck.
Are you talk a walker?
There's a ghost in a monkey fucking
genius and you got to solve your cock
and she's got to give him money.
That's great.
I guess it's a brilliant even fuck up,
but give him money to bless you with
this girl.
Look like there's gotta be a picture of
this dummy.
Not so far.
I don't really want to see a picture.
I'll be sad.
Poor Gal,
his name was Wang.
Gi Won.
Brilliant.
Huang h.
U.
A.
N.
G.
I a grammar school dog.
It was that little train just doing the
back that got fucking days.
There will be through fucking paperclip
said,
look,
he's a gangster.
He's getting his dick sucked and getting
paid.
There really is funny,
man.
That is classic.
That's classic type Shit.
He explained the ghosts
in her vagina were preventing her boss
from falling in love with her.
Oh my God.
Check this.
So she must've come to him and said,
I want my boss to fall in love with me.
And so,
so she was a conniver man.
So he convinced her because the ghosts
in her vagina were preventing her boss
from falling in love with her.
Holy Shit ghost that he could easily
catch with his penis.
Did you fucking arrest that guy?
Come on man,
because they don't have high five there.
That's rude.
Arresting this guy for that is rude.
You should be able to go to the Cota
court.
And he said,
well your honor,
what I told her was that her vagina was
haunted and uh,
the only way she's going to be able to
steal her boss away from his wife is uh,
if uh,
she let me fuck her and catch the goes
with my tech,
get the fuck out of my court.
You'd be like,
get your lunchbox and get the fuck out.
You wanted to sue him for what you,
you,
you thought that was true?
He thought really he was going to get
the,
the ghost out with his Dick.
Get the fuck out my car while the cops
and tell them,
listen,
I got arrested guy.
He stuck his Dick in my fucking whatever
ghost in there.
Okay.
If fucking Julie lied to me any time,
I guess it's the money.
It was the 3000,
250 bucks.
If they had a problem with it,
but meanwhile,
how can they prove it?
She probably wrote a check.
Oh,
how can they prove it?
How can they prove that he didn't get
the ghost out?
Smell it.
ECTOPLASM
smell it.
Smell.
If it smells like it could be rigged
game though.
She waits right to you starting.
She farted in your face.
It's a fucking crazy world out there
though.
You can follow people and Patty thing.
Well,
you can definitely talk some people into
almost anything into anything.
Go to a farmer's market on a Sunday.
Just any of those low Kenyan farmers
just stay in the back.
There's always go to burning man.
Oh,
they got the hat on the whole fucking
thing.
How many people,
how many people do you think you'd talk
at a joint called if you went to burning
man?
Three
you could ask for three.
I gotta have a plan.
I got to have a plant when it takes
them.
You know why?
The reason why they have to suck your
dick to drink from the anointing of the
sick,
the whole thing.
They gotta,
you know,
you gotta,
you gotta have a plan.
You just can't go to burning man and
drop knowledge on bitches.
You gotta have a plan.
You have to have a little bit of a plan.
But then from there you can make it up
as you go along.
And it's tremendous because you could
get a soldier and his girlfriend and
then his girlfriend.
Then you recruit two chicks and so
mother fucking Momo and you're off and
running somebody.
One of those idiots is a trust fund
baby.
It leaks with talking,
listening.
Well,
can you get from your dad?
he's such a pig.
You know,
he makes condoms and cigarettes and he
sells.
He's an asshole.
You could probably get 10,000 okay,
get 10,000 and they'll go,
yeah.
When a,
how many of those people like pretend
play kidnapped so that their dad is to
send money,
Bro.
I lived in boulder and I remember kids
coming to me and going,
listen,
give me a week.
I've got to come up with 7,500 from my,
I remember them saying they'd worked at
that the,
and then they'd walk around poor telling
people that pour and my God,
this is so hard living in boulder.
Meanwhile the driving a fucking Volvo
when an air bag the whole fucking deal.
Why not dude is really rich who drives
like beat up cars because he grew up
rich.
Yeah.
And he like,
he like has a pickup truck so he drives
a pickup truck on purpose.
Like he wants to thank and he's like as
a country guy.
Yeah.
Well you know,
I'm just trying to make it in this here
a big city.
If they're not millionaires,
well you've got to be scared of those
are the people you got to be scared of.
Well I think someone growing up in that
kind of environment,
if you,
if you grew up with like,
I mean name the name,
super rich multibillionaire parents
living on yachts and you know,
flying away to boarding school like
your,
your reality is so bizarre.
Like your reality of like the potential
of your future if you grow up and your
parents are weapons manufacturers and
your parents have an island off of
Greece and you know,
and the dad flies out there in a g five
and they're,
they're selling machine guns of Saudi
Arabia.
Like do breakfast at the presidents
house.
You'd do breakfast at fucking Clintons
and you shoot your guns with Clinton and
Bush comes over and he brings some way,
tie it up and you shoot him Bro.
That's,
I can't even fucking imagine.
I can't even fathom that you know,
being that,
but just take away,
yeah,
you're right.
You're why been there Joey Diaz,
I know you have Bohemian Grove.
I filmed them worshiping more like the
Owl God.
Have you seen that video that he did
know?
He did a video of him live from Bohemian
Grove is like Alex Jones is one of his
first videos.
They really do.
He's right.
They really do have like a ritual that
they do there if you find it online,
but I guarantee it's up there.
Alex Jones live and Bohemian Grove.
They,
they,
they find,
he goes there and these dudes there in
front of this gigantic stone owl and
they have the sticks and they say
they're going to burn the sticks like
it's an effigy.
I guess the idea behind that is the
sticks are supposed to represent a
sacrifice and in the old days they
actually used to take a person and light
them on fire.
This is Alex Jones.
He's much younger.
I was their least gentlemen hiding in
the bushes watching this site,
tannic ritual take place with your tax
dollars.
These dudes were put on robes and they
go out there with torches that that's
eyes wide shut.
That's the sound shit.
Don't,
don't,
don't fuck with the music or the sound
rather
useless.
Fine.
Now come on.
This is crazy.
This is fucking beyond crazy cause this
is real.
This is in wonder.
Alex Jones is so crazy.
If you went there live and you saw this,
you would believe that anything is
possible.
If there's some dude to have a bundle of
sticks and is there a woman that they're
pretending that they're going to
sacrifice?
Is that the idea?
Is there a woman who's like
tied up there?
I wish I knew the whole story.
See,
it looks like they got like a person
that they're going to pretend to
sacrifice them.
They burn these sticks
and it's like,
what?
Like just just knowing that that's real.
This is in Texas.
I Dunno.
It seems like it would be.
Let's look it up.
Bohemian Grove.
Hold on.
Let's do the soundtrack is amazing.
It's so tracking that Friday.
It was for this.
No,
it's in California.
Oh my God.
That makes sense.
So southern though,
you're like,
nope.
Did it.
It sounded,
you know,
where'd this happen?
Angeles.
Avoid this fucking neighborhood with
this APP.
I slide failure right somewhere in
northern cal pass Visalia before San
Francisco.
You'll kill it.
You pull over for a Taco that done Alex
Jones,
you Bohemian Grove live famous footage.
This is what tuned me into the
Illuminati Ladies Gentlemen.
There was a dark time before that where
they hid in the shadows.
Wow.
This is real.
That's so strange.
I mean,
even if it's just for a goof and people
go,
oh,
you're just misconstruing what's going
on there,
there,
there the,
the ideas just for fun.
What kind of an asshole stands around in
a robe waiting for all this stupid shit
to take place.
Like this is taking place for over like
15,
20 minutes and they're all in order.
Leaf line,
like waiting on this in this very weird
ritual.
Like who would want to participate in
this?
So the idea is that a,
there's a Washington Post article about
it had better music,
it'd be cool.
I mean like look at that as I'm going to
fire people dressed up.
There's not even moving,
it's not like they're dancing.
Like what if they had great music and
then just standing still.
See that's much better.
Does kind of get us pulled from Youtube.
You fuck the digital signatures,
goddammit.
Oh yeah.
So there's an article here in the
Washington Post about this Bohemian
Grove thing and uh,
these guys are standing around these
gigantic redwood trees and shit.
And there are all these like really
super rich guys.
It says two folk future US presidents,
Ronald Reagan and Richard Nixon are
pictured with Harvey Hancock.
Not to be confused with Herbie Hancock
or herb.
Was that the guy,
the love bug?
No,
Herbie Hancock was the a musician,
right.
Harvey Hancock Standing and others at
the Bohemian Grove in the summer of
1967.
Wow.
It's amazing.
Ronald Reagan and Richard Nixon,
check this out.
Nixon said in his Watergate tapes,
he said,
if I were to choose the speech that gave
me the most pleasure and satisfaction in
my political career,
it would be the leg speech chip.
The Bohemian Grove in six 1967 is this
speech traditionally
was off the record and receive no
publicity at the time.
Uh,
but then he said that the Bahamian Grove
that I attended from time to time,
the easterners and the other came there
and it became the most faggy God damn
thing I've ever,
you could ever imagine.
Richard Nixon Nixon said that San
Francisco crowd that goes there,
it's just terrible.
I mean,
I won't shake hands with anybody from
San Francisco.
Nixon said that
terrible human being.
Look at this picture of uh,
this,
uh,
this photo of um,
Ronald Reagan and Richard Nixon talking
to this or this guy.
It's really strange.
Like they really do have a place where
like these old rich elite guys get
together and sit down and talk about
shit.
Like they really did have places like
that where they would meet up and these
special locations like that.
That idea has always been like this
wacky conspiracy theory thing that the
elites get together and they meet and
they wear robes.
But no,
they're fucking really do like look at
that look,
they're hanging around in the forest and
Nixon and Ronald Reagan and their with
their,
their dinner jackets on Colonel Sanders
and couple of it looks like John Wayne
the far lower right,
doesn't it?
Yeah,
it looks like a little John Wayne Ish.
Weird.
All dudes so strange.
Well it's going to be like,
dude,
not one course on,
it's going to be like,
well,
long after these guys are gone,
like law.
I mean,
obviously Reagan and Nixon are both gone
now,
but I mean like long,
long after anybody who's alive now in
the future we're going to have like a,
just a sort of a whisper of what
happened there,
right?
Know something's going to find the
letter,
which has gotta be proof of picture,
a photograph of something.
Someone's going to write some crazy shit
down.
Chick wasn't that picture of 1957 she
was never seen that to that.
Not to Wayne,
an attic somewhere and I'll be here.
So 2,708 Acre compound,
2000 skews me.
It's 2,700 Acre compound in Monte Rio,
California for two weeks of heavy
drinking super secret talks,
druid worship.
The group insists that they're simply
revering the redwoods and other rituals,
their purpose to escape the frontier
culture or uncivilized interest of
common man.
Wow.
This is the fucking Washington Post
wrote this.
The people that gather at Bohemian Grove
who've included prominent business
leaders,
former US presidents,
musicians and oil barons are told that
weaving spiders come not here,
meaning that business deals are to be
left outside.
One exception was in 1942 when planning
for the Manhattan project took place at
the grove leading to the creation of the
atomic bomb.
God Damn Joey Diaz at answer me this
truthfully.
How hard that edible kick in about 15
minutes ago.
I have no idea.
He thinks you're talking about
Bohemian rhapsody got to a certain point
where I saw him checkout.
I saw his eyes roll back and I'm like,
oh,
okay.
I'm good.
I've been good,
but Chiba chew that cheat sheet.
The deep waters.
What's the 70 what?
What does that really,
really ground with the pain?
I took those 70 milligrams.
What does a normal dose?
It's like 02030707175 is the Deca one 75
one 75 the one that makes people fucking
cringe.
That's scary,
right?
That's a scary one.
That's too scary.
That's a little too real.
You're making me an hour's becomes too
real.
I saw that movie trailer that was pulled
that you were in.
It looked really good.
Actually.
I pulled everything.
He had a great line in it.
I'm not going to say what it is.
What are you talking about?
Joey d is in this picture.
What are you talking about from movie
deal?
They put up,
what is it?
Took it down their road movie.
Why they took it down?
I have no idea.
One of the rose took it though,
but they put it up there was somebody
else put it up.
I don't know if it's a leaked a trailer.
Oh,
how do you leak a trailer?
Uh,
somebody that's paid to edit it and gets
paid $10 an hour and he just puts it
online or something like that.
So he made his own trailer.
It's amazing how he gets paid to do it
and he's probably at home sitting in
Burbank.
The story,
it's something fucking unique when like
the high level people who robbed those
movies that don't rob the movie from the
movie theater with the camera no more.
No,
they robbed him.
They tap into Warner brothers or Fox.
They all Shoney.
They tapped him like the week before the
movie gets released or a month before it
gets released.
They take the movie out,
it's backwards.
It traveled backwards.
They have to unwind it,
whatever.
Boom.
Back in business.
Is that what they do?
So they did LTP sites.
Veit is out before the movie's out.
Yeah.
The movies in this country come out
three days before you go see him on
Friday.
Some of them do.
If you go into any big market and
Detroit and New York with fucking this
bad ass motherfuckers Tuesday you could
get,
you could get whatever movie you want
even though the movie's not coming out
til Friday.
Do you remember when you used to be able
to buy them on the street?
Right.
And they were these VHS tape op
politics.
They had a cover that was a copy of the
real cover and it was like obviously
like a printer piece of Pr,
you know,
like a common computer printer copy.
I made good,
maybe allegedly made great money selling
pop fiction,
a bootlegs on campus.
I've never bought a fucking illegal
film.
I was always scared to stop for those
things,
especially in New York City.
I was always just don't stop just
sketching out a whole fucking problem.
You know?
It's a lot of times I bought them and
they were empty.
There was nothing there.
I knew guys in the 70s taking boxes like
crazy Eddie and putting fucking bricks
in them and wrapping them at home and
they're in a corner and also can you
pull up and you're like,
what do you got?
And they're like,
speakers,
$50 at 200 of the event,
you're not going to unwrap them.
They're wrapped,
you know,
put them in your car.
You're going to get to fucking bricks.
Yeah.
That was real common.
The pulling up and asking you if you
want to buy some stereotypes.
We had some extras.
Yeah.
I don't want nothing.
I don't want nothing to go keep driving.
You know?
They had that crazy Eddie's story.
That was brilliant.
It's a weird thing about urban
environments,
isn't it?
Yeah,
you can always,
it's always a scam.
It's getting rough.
But I knew that was one point where the
scam went south.
There was one point where I heard you
hear shit that people were selling
thermostats and the glass is broken,
you know,
and then you just say,
fuck it.
Why even started going,
I might get a great deal or I might get
bullshit.
I got to go back and looking for the
fucking guy in the next day for $8 is it
really worth the aggravation?
You know?
But I remember going back to New York in
[inaudible] 94 after I got divorced and
a friend of mine goes,
I got a job selling cars.
I need it.
Then he goes,
how much money?
You ain't got to go about 600 bucks.
He took me to a building,
Bro.
He took me to a building in Harlem at
the top two floors.
But like going into the gap.
Wow.
And the,
the original clothes were on there with
the original prices and it was like 75%
off.
And you got it.
Let's try remember for like 600 getting
three suits and a pair of shoes and two
dress shirts or something,
you know,
nice suits.
Like wow.
Like,
you know,
because there's something for third,
somebody robbed them off the truck,
but they had blenders in there.
They had TVs,
they had tables,
they had everything.
Everything was brand new.
If it,
you know,
it was probably headed to Ikea or
something like that.
Who the fuck knows?
Wow.
They had buildings in New York when I
was growing up.
They pull up,
but type of guys from the neighborhood
that you knew how to job,
but APA trucking or one of those things,
one of those trucking firms and they get
shit every fucking Thursday.
They ain't got shit every fucking
Thursday when like a big,
when I was a kid fucking the trains
would move Honda many trails and the
many trails or the best motorcycle you
could buy for a kid.
We didn't have balls.
It was 50 it was 50 cc and it was
automatic.
I had one,
I bought one for real.
My mother bought me one for real and
then we found out that you could steal
them off the train that came through
Erie,
Lackawanna and you would go down there
and somebody would jump on the train and
break the seal,
take the shit off,
thrown into the weeds.
And then somebody had have to come back
with a truck because in those days you
put those together,
they didn't come.
And built.
The Tigers won,
the bottom was on,
you got to put the seed on,
got to put the steering wheel on,
you gotta put all that shit on him.
It's amazing dog.
So we found that when they were coming
in and you take three or four of them,
keep one,
all three of them,
there were 200 retail.
So that meant they were probably $85.
What's in there?
Like a big amount of profit for like
some organized crime in New York.
Cause they get steal things off the
docks and then resell them someplace.
It costs you nothing.
You could sell it for whatever the fuck
you want.
You can undercut everybody.
Why do you think stealing cocaine in the
80s are so popular?
Because I control the mark.
I just got 30 kilos,
then you're going to pay 44.
I'm yourself at 32
was the last time anybody ever offered
you would buy something that was stolen.
As soon as I moved to California and
start really,
you stop talking the boom Shacka lacka
eat.
Oh that's right.
Yeah.
But he had to uh,
dildos the other day and I'm like,
wow,
these are like brand new soccer locker
or the other guy.
Nice guy.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah,
but who's the guy with the lighters?
Ah,
that's uh,
you have another crazy name?
Yeah.
Fuck
yeah.
I just saw him the other day.
Yeah,
he hangs out at the rainbow now,
but,
and males,
but we checked like had this dildo and
I'm like,
wow,
this is like brand new.
And I'm like,
but it's not,
why am I telling
you?
Remember that Kennison talked about the
Roxy way back or the rainbow way back in
his fucking HBO special.
That's how crazy the rainbows band.
You see the sunset strip movie I told
you about and they tell you about this.
No
Strip just came out on showtime on
demand.
I think you could ask it on iTunes.
It's a documentary about sun stripped
starting from the beginning all the way
through the mafia,
all the way through Ciro's it goes
through and all this shit about the,
there though hooker houses that were
everywhere.
I had no idea about like there was like,
uh,
whatever.
Like houses,
like rich people would go to and just
had tons of hookers in it and uh,
you,
it talks about everything and he'd go
buy it and you're just going by these
buildings that you go by every day and
like,
Holy Shit.
That was the hooker house.
Yeah.
It came out in 2012 got mad reviews,
man.
Oh,
it's got amazing people in it.
It's got an amazing a review online.
It says a documentary on the famous Los
Angeles Street.
Wow.
Yeah.
So yeah.
It's got five stars or four stars here.
Yeah.
I'm getting that shit tonight.
Is it available on iTunes?
Yup.
It's really well done.
There's a lot of people in it.
And uh,
if there is a place in,
in like the world that I've ever been to
that I feel like it's haunted with the
memories of the past,
not necessarily haunted,
but haunted with the,
the memories of the past.
It's that area.
Yeah.
They talk about that a lot.
So haunted aspect.
And they talk about how it used to be
like papa,
not poppy fields,
like something weird here.
Before it was Ciro's Boulevard,
famous boulevard glorified and movie.
You walking.
I'm seeing you.
They go through a lot of
comedy.
Wow.
Doheny to crescent heights.
There's a lot of ghosts I believe in
sacred places and I believe that this
is,
it's a sacred place.
That strip is like,
where are you leaving?
Come back.
Yeah.
You can almost taste.
It's about titillation and sex.
Hollywood itself is a bag
sexual appeal and the strip instead of a
patient of that,
your dreams can start out there and
you'd be,
we'll end there.
You know,
if you don't watch your shit you will
die that night and it will be because
he's too talkative or weird.
Jason.
Yeah,
he was talking to that other guy who was
just a weird combo.
Who was the other guy called?
No,
I think it's that guy that's also comic
battle.
The God damn site.
Amazing Fun.
Could not have happened any place else
and don't you ever forget it?
It was so alive.
Honestly.
I mean you tell mom,
mom hits viper room walk.
Nobody would ever come and be like,
you guys can't do that here.
Are you crazy?
It seems like this is a place where
people sort of come for refuge.
Sunset strip is a civilization or the
broken hearted and mistreated.
The uncle.
Lucky I'm do love
die.
You might as well die.
Die Front of all of them.
Why is that going to make up on the
white songs like the mayor sunset strip
or something weird like that?
Well,
why is he?
I don't know.
Okay.
Wow.
That looks bad ass.
Yeah,
that was really good.
I just realized how fortunate I am to
have been able to perform that.
I can just hit me like Jesus.
They could go back.
I go to the laugh factory from time to
time.
Would you go back to the store?
No,
never.
No.
Wait,
if I guys,
if you guys came with me,
what the fuck or does this just kidding.
What are you,
do you,
are you a ghostbuster?
Yeah,
I call it dumb show on Tuesday.
dumps on Tuesdays.
Great.
Well he does.
Is he like as a fun thing he does.
It's not just stand up.
He fucks around with the crowd a lot.
He tortures them.
Oh yeah.
Well he's great at that,
you know,
and he does his podcast from there too
sometimes.
You know,
I did the podcast,
I did it once with Jamie Masada once.
Yeah.
Once I got a call on you,
you guys went back to the comedy store.
Like seriously,
I'd have been one of the most amazing
things ever.
Just it's just like having like the
Rogan does Tuesday so hot,
like in the main room sold out every
week and it's not happening.
Awesome.
Yeah,
but why would we do it there when we do
it at the Ice House tomorrow night,
boom.
Joey Diaz is doing his podcast there and
then boom,
I'm there with Eddie F's and Brian Cowen
tomorrow 10:00 PM I see that you see the
differences,
the energy at the ice houses all like
there's a long history of it and there's
also what we bring there.
We've been bringing their,
this plenty's paradise.
Hell son.
This is not negative cause no murdered
people.
There's no like holes in the fucking
basement covered in some mat with dead
people.
Okay.
Would people don't realize,
we're not exaggerating,
there was Ciro's nightclub.
It was owned by Bugsy Siegel.
The Bugsy Siegel.
I mean that guy was a gangster.
That guy had have killed people.
That's back when you could just kill
people.
Yeah.
And that dirty,
crazy street,
that nutty energy of that place has,
it only makes sense to people dying
there.
The Piano Player,
Jeff Scott recently posted on his
Facebook,
uh,
the tunnel going,
underneath the street where they used to
have like take the bodies underneath to
where you used to be something else.
Yeah.
To the house.
The house.
So yeah,
that was,
well,
I don't know if that's true,
but that was the room rose was that in
the back of the main room,
there was a doorway to a tunnel and the
tunnel led up the hill to crest hill
where the mansion was because there
were,
the property was sold together
allegedly.
But that's like one of those things like
fucking it kabod crane.
There is a tunnel.
That's true.
There's a lot of it.
Go see it right now.
If they have a tunnel,
somebody died.
That's all I need to know.
There's a lot of shit done.
It is a room then that goes this way and
that cuts across Nica keep going to
different things.
There's a lot of these ships shooting
the shooting holes.
One of the ideas in this questions,
everything show was to go and spend the
night at a haunted house and I was
thinking this is no better place to stay
in the store basement at the comedy
store too.
Yeah.
That would be terrified.
I'm shit my pants called call the bow.
You should tell a story on stage about
how the time where when he was young,
we'll have him come in here and tell it
some day.
Um,
when he was young,
he was staying at the store and he's out
of the store.
Like his wife kicked him out or
something like that and he got,
it was forced to stay at the store.
He was sleeping on the stage.
It's like,
this is,
why am I here to make my dreams happen
man.
I'm not letting some chick getting my
way,
so I'm just going to lie down here.
And he said he's lying down.
He told it on stage,
it was like a Halloween show we had in
the main room.
It was fucking great.
And he was like,
and so I'm onstage and I hear clink,
clink,
like there's chairs moving,
it is pitch black.
And I'm like,
hey,
it's me,
Carl.
You know,
I had uh,
had nowhere else to stay.
Silence is one,
but he was a doorman back then,
you know,
like what?
Right before Kennison and even made it.
And he said he heard another clink
clink,
like he had another chair and they said,
and then out of nowhere,
two hands grabbed his legs and dragged
them to the edge of the stairs.
And he said there was no one there.
He said he didn't see anything.
By the time he got up,
he scrambled,
the person,
whatever it was,
just disappeared.
And he said he freaked out,
ran out of there.
What's a great story?
It could have been easily been boom,
Shaka Laka.
Did you really,
you saw him perform there?
No,
I saw him by the belly room going up the
stairs one night.
What do you mean you saw a ghost?
You're shaking your head.
Yes.
Okay.
Come out of a pussy.
I was up next.
Jesus was up next to the other two and I
was standing by the thing there.
I kept seeing there's a light on the top
of the belly room.
There's a big red light dog and you're
still watching the comment.
And I had like two away.
So it was that comic on one more before
me.
So that was watching and waiting and
killing time.
And I kept seeing something,
keep going past my,
you see the life.
How many days had you been awake?
He had,
it wasn't that I didn't do bull going
stays.
I didn't blow when I got off stage and
I'm sitting there going,
what the fuck is this light?
And finally I look up,
you know how you wore that stupid long
jacket?
It was like,
I saw the tail end of the jacket.
I went upstairs.
It was nobody up there dog.
I saw it.
I saw my own two fucking eyes,
which I never felt.
No.
My liver got chased.
Nobody pulled me base,
has a story where he was upstairs and
they heard them banging on the door.
Uh,
crazy core record more has a story where
the,
she heard music in the fucking main
room.
Like all band music,
like the titanic type music home.
Who is the older guy that was a veteran?
Brett.
A lot of people are different things
that,
you know,
I didn't,
I never got cards DePaul.
I know that the original room has a
weird energy and you're right,
the sunsets trip does have something
special.
There's something there.
There's something that,
there's something that points at that
comedy store.
The big mistake they going to do is
they're going to knock that down and
build something over it.
It's going to be like a carry movie,
the hands and they come out of the
ground.
I mean,
that's the truth guys.
There's something that somebody
committed suicide there people gave you
that lives there.
How many people died and didn't make it
as comics and a fucking shore it's
warranted.
What about the guy that jumped off the
roof?
Sure.
That fucking places haunted.
Yeah,
sure were taunted.
So that building in Gardner,
all those buildings,
people in those buildings,
bro,
people got a straight,
legit people say this block is on,
on garden to mind.
I'll come by dre buildings there.
Then haunted that many people killed
themselves.
Those buildings coming out here.
Look at this fucking young kid that I
used himself last week from a Disney
show,
29 years old.
He's on fucking Rizzoli and isles
fucking black kid queen.
Nine years old with a shotgun.
I go to do the podcast.
I go to make a right mess capsule.
All my fucking corny.
It wasn't that fucking building there.
What possesses people?
He wasn't on drugs.
That kid I used to go down to a one hop
can go with that kid.
What possesses people to do that shit?
Who knows Hollywood that time?
Shane.
You know how many Judy can't see Audi's
back?
She doesn't the Haha cafe.
Why would Judy can't see?
He tried to make a comeback.
I don't get it.
I just saw her.
That lasted like 30 minutes.
Yeah,
it's hardening and yelling.
These people come out here and they get
crazy man and you know,
I'm very happy.
I was talking to a grandma would call to
us,
invite us to the podcast convention and
I go,
Graham,
do you know that me and you are with the
same manager in 2000 we're still here.
Whether we're fucking rich or
successful,
where the TV show,
we're still here,
no car crashes.
We have an old deed.
We're here.
I'll fucking lucky a week dog.
Oh,
we're very lucky to have gone through
what we've gone through at the store and
having a great time and the comedy that
I just saw that I had goosebumps.
I'm a fucking fat ex felon from North
Bergen,
New Jersey.
I was at the comedy store doing blow
development,
getting better,
seeing the fucking world,
walking to the store,
walking from the union on Tuesday night
to the store and walking back to the
laugh factory and we used to walk the
standard also standard eat the blue
cheese burgers.
Yeah.
Fucking delicious.
Come on us is incredible.
I remember that Carnegie it that sold
the lighters the first week I was the
guy.
Yeah,
the first weekend monkey ball.
The first Monday I was ever here,
I walked into the fucking comedy store
and Don Paris put me on stage.
Thank God I knew Eddie Griffin.
He put me on a Monday night.
Don's barriers still had the shorts on.
It's still had the balloons on.
Wow.
Cause the next day they told me to go to
the laugh factory.
That's where you went on Tuesdays and
you stood on wine or Dang,
you did three minutes and I still don't
whine all day.
Guess who was on line with me all day?
Monkey balls and he knew the whole
history of comedy in La.
Who you had a sign with who was going to
see you?
I thought this guy was a master comic
and he went on stage and he lost his
voice.
I never laughed so hard on my wife.
He went up there and my son all day,
he's talking telling stories now he's
like me,
me,
me dying.
That was monkey balls.
Then he became a lighter salesman and
rings wheels.
Beat him.
He always had those lighters with
titties.
Brian counting and Don Paris.
Yeah.
Brian Cowan and Don Perez have this
thing where Don Barris pretends to Bang
Brian Count in his booty hole.
He gets his pants down and everything
and they have this thing.
They act it out and it's so realistic.
He presses,
he presses counts mouth against his cock
sucking.
It makes it like he's pulling his cock
out,
jerks off on him and finishes it and
it's,
it's made it extra special by the fact
that Don Barris without wearing a
costume is doing this in a jumpsuit.
He wears a tracksuit naturally.
Like it's not like he dressed up for
this role where he could pose cock out
really easy.
No,
it's just,
it's a part of his thing and on top of
that,
dawn Buress is rumored to have a cock
size of your arm.
That's what I understand.
That's the room every time he had been.
We're about to pull it out on stage.
I get out of the room,
I don't want,
I don't want to get depressed.
That's the one thing,
man.
I mean,
if you don't have a giant Dick and the
other guys that giant Turkey like,
wow,
well what the hell?
I mean,
you could always get rich,
you know,
making enough money.
You could buy a nice house too.
But if a guy's got a giant Dick,
he's got a giant deck.
He just got,
it was,
I forget it was like a year ago or
something like that.
He had a bone.
If for some reason he wanted to show a
girl and the audience and he was just
like outlining it with his hand.
Like,
look how big this is,
honey.
You know?
Like he said,
it's like trying to like,
it's took a 12 inch Dick,
right?
It's a giant fat dick.
It's not a skinny 12 inches either.
It's not like one of those white guys in
the movies where it's long.
But you're like,
yeah,
but it's like,
it's tapered.
The beginning of the end of it,
it's like small.
It's weird.
You know,
there's some long and unimpressive.
Don Buress is a dick.
It looks like a big German Dick.
You know,
like a big Austrian Dick.
Yeah.
Which you would imagine some fucking
hiker would have.
Joey.
Dan's done.
Look at this.
Think about Dixie.
He's
shaking his head like,
yeah,
I understand.
I got a big Dick to cock sucker.
I need this shit.
Totally like diamond back.
We don't,
we don't need this shit if anybody needs
to.
Shit.
Listen.
Is there any more tickets to you
Wednesday night at the icehouse?
Yes,
there are eight 626-5778EEN-9TY whatever
the fuck.
So Joey is up the ice house.
Eight o'clock eight 30 come on a 10
stick around man.
Do a spot.
Those spot.
Wayne store.
You're not going.
He doesn't not going to do two shows in
a night.
It's most likely not happen.
I'll call of conduit tomorrow.
I got yes.
Yes.
Tomorrow Night Martin Kampmann versus
calls audios against called Cowboy
Cerrone.
Yes.
So it was a great fucking car.
Tomorrow and then we're going to
Milwaukee.
Yes.
We've got a great short,
the paps is only a hundred tickets left
rock.
Last time we had six circles for people
smoking reefer.
Bazookas eating edibles.
Somebody made a tray.
Black security was going to fucking take
broken home that we're all gonna Miss
Shit.
Oh,
they were the nicest,
nicest fucking people.
Those girls,
they took care of me.
We made a video of him.
Yeah,
so I'm looking forward to going to
Milwaukee.
Thank you for coming out.
We're going to have a fucking blast.
We're going to have a great time,
but I'm the one that got them on Friday
the 13th or roping.
So don't think that we don't appreciate
the fuck out of you guys,
right?
We do.
You know,
we talking about it all the time.
We know that we're incredibly lucky in
that we're wearing this weird situation
where we have like the nicest,
I didn't want calm fans.
The people that come out to these shows
that are the nicest people periods does
humans,
family,
they're just,
it's in the atmosphere is just cool as
fuck.
After the shows and these are a few
people get real nervous and the hands
get sweaty and that those,
they're strange.
I love him for the most.
Fuck,
come on down.
We'll just put the older one on.
Don't be hugging me with a fucking stink
bomb under your shirt pastor.
How many times though when you take
pictures of dudes,
they just completely sweaty.
I'm sweaty too so I don't get
nervous.
I tell him please don't touch me cause
I'm sweaty and they don't give a fuck.
So fuck.
They want to touch you and you go home
and take the shirt off and put it on the
couch and next day just take a whiff of
it.
Smells like fucking the chick with the
ghost in the snatch.
That's yeah,
this is the checks that took care of us
last time.
Look at it.
This is going to be bossing the walk.
You don't fuck asleep but kept the line
going.
They kept everybody in line cause we've
been come after shows,
we'll meet people and we,
we've been doing it for forever.
Like I don't know man.
I don't know how it started,
how it started,
where we just hang around after shows
but it was a long ass time ago.
It don't matter.
We just decided we hang out afterwards
at all.
It makes,
well,
you know what,
we decided and we even talked about it
and we decided that it's a,
even if we want to leave,
like it's way better for them if they
get to hang out and take a picture with
us and get to meet us.
It's a better experience,
you know,
so that's like,
it's part of the experience.
It's a,
they,
they go to the show,
they have a good time and then you know,
afterwards were hanging around with them
and talk to them and take photos with
them and it's so,
it's not just,
you know,
you're not just,
we're not just doing a comedy show and
then getting the fuck out of there.
Like we appreciate you guys coming in as
well.
I walked into the UFC,
people start yelling,
you're like,
like,
no,
no.
Come on you motherfucker.
Those people at the UFC,
you're crazy.
And sometimes I have to leave.
Like I do interviews afterwards and the
scream,
it's like I can't,
I got to go.
They're going to fucking to drag me out
of here.
They'll keep you there forever.
They bribed the security and let them
get up front though.
It's great man.
I love every fucking minute of it.
I really,
well this the the UFC too,
they give it a lot of access to fans.
Those fanex bows and Q and A's.
It passed the way it's supposed to be.
It is the way it's costing it and then
no other leisure learn it from Dana
White.
That's what you gotta do to be
successful.
People want the full experience.
People will pay.
They get fucking arm barred by chocolate
down and you know what show would I?
Oh yeah.
If you're fun,
if you're going to the fan expo,
learn how to roll.
I don't care whether you're a white belt
of Brown,
but they're not going to kill you.
They're gonna.
You're gonna get one great thing on the
billing and the picture.
A memory for life.
I could never do that.
And I went to June,
I went to like a Willis reads basketball
camp.
There was no pictures then.
You didn't take a picture with no body.
You web was all from memory.
He signed the tee shirt.
Big fucking deal.
Carlos condit had a great video of him,
uh,
sparring with guys like a rolling with
Cassie went to a,
like a,
an army base.
Richie rich frank has done it to
people.
Yeah.
Since done it a bunch of times.
A Henna.
Gracie did it too.
They go and they'll go to a base that's
right.
Mirror against babyface assassin.
Who are on this card walking.
Yeah.
We've got a great car.
We got my man motherfucking clay.
Guido against a,
who the fuck is oh,
the Spanish kid.
The one that lost the Aldo in Brazil.
He's part of the team.
Alpha male.
Dwayne Bank trains them.
Um,
which one little hold on little funny
little kid.
Little Kid.
He lost the Jose Aldo.
The knee to the face.
Oh,
Chad Mendez.
Mendez is fighting 45.
Yeah,
he's fighting.
Try and menders.
Yeah,
baby
baby.
We got some good boxing fights this
week.
Yeah,
I'll read the card off to right.
Yeah.
Give me the under card baby.
I don't know what the fuck is here.
We got,
oh Jesus.
We got a lot of shit.
Me,
Brandon.
Vera.
What versus Ben Rothwell.
God Damn.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
We gotta crazy.
Eric Coke versus Dustin.
Tim Barnett versus mirror clay.
Guido versus Chad Mendez.
Jamie Varner versus glaze and t bow.
Oh Shit.
This is a grateful,
some great fire in car.
And then of course the title fight.
Benson Henderson versus Anthony Pettis.
That is fucking nuts.
Rufus will be there Friday jumping up
and down and shit on side kicks for the
Jesus.
That's an amazing fight,
man.
Henderson is Anthony Pettis is going to
be fucking insanity.
You know pennys has a 56% Kale rate.
56% that mother is a beast.
I forgot he fucked up.
Joe Lozoff.
Jeez dude with a head kick.
How about Donald Cerrone fucked him up
with a body kit.
No,
no,
no.
Up.
His left leg is nasty man.
He's a bad motherfucker.
He remembered when he hits the wrong
with that crazy knee to the showtime
knee.
He bounces off the cage and pops knee
through a small opening,
catches him in the face.
I kids,
wild man and so's Henderson Henderson's
a fucking beast.
He's only gotten better since we want
the title.
It's only gotten better since he lost
the title to Pennys who's amazing.
Five different fire than we lost a pet
broke and this is going to be as
amazing.
Great weeks is going to be amazing.
Yeah.
This is,
it's a sec sick card sink weekend.
So we'll see guys at the Pabst theater
and we'll see you tomorrow night at the
Ice House.
And also tomorrow we're going to have a
podcast here with the one and only
Everlast and Everlast has released a
new,
um,
he released a new acoustic only CD and
he got the idea from doing it,
from performing on podcasts,
from getting on our podcast and,
and doing it for the first time
performing,
you know,
acoustic like that and getting this
massive reaction.
So all the love is what inspires them.
Yeah.
He actually pulled me last time he was
here,
he pulled me into the car and goes,
Brian,
I need something to tell you something.
And he showed me,
cause it's supposedly,
I hope it's still on there,
but he said,
uh,
we talked about,
I said that you should do like a how
that one song jump jump up and down,
you should do an acoustic version of,
and he's like,
no,
I hate those songs about it.
He's like,
he played it for me in his car and he
and he's like,
how is this?
I think I was like,
what the f
awesome.
Are you allowed to say that you
breaking,
I mean it's out now,
right?
No,
I think it is out.
I think it's out right now.
I think it came out today.
I think it's out Tuesday.
Cool.
Yeah,
it's going to be sick.
He's,
I like him acoustically even better than
the house paint.
Me Too.
And I think house of pain's a mate.
What does that song,
a little Miss America or that one song?
God Damn,
that's a good fucking song.
And ever since what it's like,
like people like caught his,
his,
his acoustic shit is like way deeper.
It's way more emotional and touching.
Jump around.
It's always going to be like an anthem.
It's always going to be like a cool song
in here.
It's awesome
when we have diverse and he played it
for me.
Can I pump my,
uh,
dates?
Yeah.
I'm going to be with Tony Hinchcliffe a
September 26 at stand up live at
Phoenix,
Arizona.
In the following day,
I'm going to Ohio,
Columbus,
Ohio at woodlands backyard with Thompson
Dura,
Christina at gate and Tony and me.
All right,
well see you dirty freaks tomorrow.
And uh,
may Odin bless you all.
We love the shit out of.
Yeah.
So you soon
monsters.
They can go fuck themselves.
They know who they are.
Listen,
stamps.com enter in the code word J r e.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and use the
codeword Rogan,
uh,
audible.com forward slash.
Joe.
We love the fuck out of you guys.
We'll see you soon.